est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial
or dans la période actuelle il est
difficile de dire précisément combien
d'enfants sont concernés car en fait on
a très peu de visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous pouvez non pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'après eux mêmes et
dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités tenues toujours à bonne
distance et nos reporters voici les
titres
une mobilisation interdite par la
préfecture de police en ce moment même
devant le tribunal judiciaire de paris
rassemblement en hommage à adama traoré
jeune homme noir décédé en 2016 lors
d'une interpellation le comité de
soutien à la famille traoré veut
également dénoncer les violences
policières et soutenir les manifestants
américains mobilisés depuis la mort de
georgia fioles freud est justement
nouvelle nuit de violence une semaine
après la mort de ce dernier lors d'une
interpellation policière donald trump
menace de déployer l'armée pour éteindre
les protestations qui selon l'onu met en
évidence des discriminations raciales
endémique 1 le professeur raoul défendre
son travail et règle nouvelle fois ses
comptes alors que la publication de
l'étude du lot 7 la semaine dernière
avait conduit le ms à suspendre les
essais cliniques de la chloroquine
notamment en france passer à la noue par
certains scientifiques et à la revue a
été contrainte de publier un ver atom à
propos d'une erreur de codage
[Musique]
le traçage presque sur la bonne voie le
lancement de l'application stop kobe est
effective depuis aujourd'hui sur google
très rapidement sur apple un outil
polémique qui permet de tracer des
personnes positives au commis 19
utilisable sur la base du volontariat
son but est de réduire l'impact du
coronavirus en identifiant les chaînes
de transmission
[Musique]
un rassemblement donc en mémoire d'adama
traoré interdit par la préfecture de
police à paris ce soir une manifestation
organisée devant le tribunal judiciaire
par le comité de soutien à la famille à
damas une
ce jeune homme noir un mort lors d'une
interpellation juillet 2016 et contre
les violences policières mobilisation
qui n'a fait l'objet d'aucune
déclaration préalable selon la
préfecture de police dans un communiqué
on vient de l'apprendre une contre-opa
expertise médicale indépendante réalisée
à la demande des proches du jeune homme
valide l'asphyxient par le placage
ventrale et contredit ainsi la dernière
expertise judiciaire disculpant les
gendarmes
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
par téléphone avec thomas abonnés notre
reporter présent sur place bonsoir
thomas il semble y avoir beaucoup de
monde quelle est l'atmosphère sur place
il ya plusieurs milliers de personnes
qui pour attendre et a depuis environ
huit heures mairie par 30 sur le parvis
du tribunal de paris où la très
nombreuse très importante qui fait
rassembler au fur et à mesure pour vous
dire donner un aperçu de la mobilisation
le parvis ne permet pas de contenir
toute la petite la population toutes les
personnes qui se sont déplacées
aujourd'hui il y en a qui sont encore
dans les rues adjacentes il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde on s'y fait rassemblés
à l'appel du collectif la vérité pour à
tamedia lather adama traoré qui étaient
présentes cac a pris la parole à de
nombreuses reprises elle est également
revenue sur cet exercice vous en avez
parlé cette expertise qui est parue cet
après midi et qui explique que le
plaquage d'entre alsina a causé le décès
du jeune homme en juillet 2016
voilà pour le contexte vous l'avez dit
également cette manifestation n'a pas
été autorisée ni un communiqué qui a été
publié dans l'après midi par la
préfecture de police de paris expliquant
qu'il n'y avait aucune autorisation pour
un tel rassemblement mais dans des ti
donc de faire interdiction énormément de
monde qui est présent dans une ambiance
pacifique beaucoup certaines portent des
masques également preuve que les
conflits et amis d'amis père pardon son
papa dans les deux merci thomas abonnés
côté anna lee
nous sommes en direct avec alexis
poulain cofondateur du monde moderne
dont soir alexis poulain merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on le
rappelle dans ce contexte de révoltes
américaine la sphère adama traoré est ce
qu'elles pourraient mettre le feu aux
poudres et pourrait être le déclencheur
d'émeutes c'est en tout cas ce que
craignent certainement les autorités
pourquoi émeutes je crois que c'est une
manifestation pacifiste pour justement
dénoncer les violences policières au
moins cette technique du placage
ventrale qui a coûté la vie à adama
traoré mais aussi l cédric joue via et à
beaucoup d'autres
évidemment elle arrive dans un contexte
où aux états unis on est dans plusieurs
centaines plus une centaine de villes
sur des émeutes suite à la mort de
georges folle comme vous le disiez en
introduction qui a été tué par une
intervention policière là encore est
évidemment il ya à la fois la solidarité
par rapport à ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis mais regardons ce qu'il se
passe en france regardons ce qui s'est
passé pendant deux ans de manifestations
de gilet jaune le nombre de blessés le
nombre de morts également inepte cet
octogénaire à marseille qui a été tué
par un tir de grenade lacrymogène
mais aussi bientôt la fête de la musique
qui va arriver le 21 juin dès confiné
j'espère que tous les français auront
une pensée pour steegmans ya qu'à nice
au ce jeune qui a disparu suite à une
charge de police à nantes à soir de fête
de la musique donc il ya un problème il
ya un problème qui fait que au sommet de
la hiérarchie personne ne veut s'en
occuper alors il ya une gpn qui fait des
enquêtes mais regardez comme c'est
compliqué d'avoir ne serait-ce qu'un
avis d'expert sur les raisons de la mort
d'adama traoré plusieurs expertises et
contre expertises
tout ça pour essayer de discuter une
technique criminelle le placage ventrale
qui devrait en fait ne plus avoir lieu
et qui est dénoncé par les associations
de droits de l'homme et pas seulement
par la famille d'adama traoré donc c'est
un vrai problème et je crois que
l'absence totale celui qu'on entend pas
sur ce sujet et à ses ministres de
l'intérieur christophe castaner qui
évite de parler de ce sujet là alors que
aujourd'hui avec des lois d'exception on
interdit toujours le rassemblement de
plus de 10 personnes
on voit bien qu'on ne peut pas dans ce
contexte là interdire une manifestation
notamment suite à la manifestation de
samedi
des sans papiers
mais aussi à maubeuge la manifestation
des ouvriers qui défendent l'usiné
renault contre les délocalisations donc
le déconfinement des colères le
déconfinement des luttes à est en train
d'avoir lieu
et pas seulement en france évidemment
les etats unis sont en première ligne
alors alexis poulain le ministre de
l'intérieur n'a pas réagi effectivement
à cette technique du placage ventrale
qui est décrié mais il a réagi à ces
attaques qui consisterait à dire que la
police serait raciste en france la
police qui protège dans ce pays les
femmes et les hommes de thoune y compris
du racisme nous dit christophe castaner
rejoint de peu par le préfet de police
de paris didier lallement qui a adressé
son soutien aujourd'hui aux policiers je
vous propose de l'écouter avant de vous
faire réagir pour les citoyens français
que nous sommes une accusation ne suffit
pas à faire une vérité la police de
l'agglomération parisienne n'est ni
violente ni raciste elle agit dans le
cadre du droit pour la liberté de tous
je ne laisserai pas salir une
institution dont le rôle dans les grands
moments de l'histoire de ce pays a été
essentielle il n'y a pas de race dans la
police pas plus que de racisées ou de
presseur raciste il ya des
fonctionnaires qui s'engage pour la
liberté l'égalité et la fraternité
et cela au quotidien alors effectivement
lexsi poulain compliqué ne pas faire le
parallèle avec ce qui se passe aux etats
unis la police française qui est accusé
en quelque sorte
voilà par certains de racisme qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire
bien il ya eu cette vidéo terrible avec
les mots racistes de policiers qui
disait il à kas noyer celui on n'a qu'à
lui met un boulet rappelez vous c'était
il ya pas si longtemps
même pas un mois il me semble il y a
parfois des dérapages évidemment des
débordements le problème c'est qu'il ya
un problème d'encadrement à quel moment
on autorise en fait cette parole à quel
moment on autorise le contrôle au faciès
à quel moment en fait on fait que oui il
y à des actes racistes dans la police en
revanche et là je suis d'accord avec le
préfet l'allemand c'est une institution
la police on peut pas dire la police
mais les policiers
c'est une institution en plus de la
diversité qui recrutent dans la france
entière
vous avez en fait une population qui est
représentatif de ce qu'est la france au
sein de la police donc oui il ya des
racistes au sein de la police comme il
ya des racistes au sein de la population
française le problème encore une fois
un de la hiérarchie c'est que les
racistes ne peuvent pas être policier de
la république ils ne peuvent pas rendre
ce service public qu'est le maintien de
l'ordre et la protection des civils donc
on a un vrai problème qui est celui en
fait des dénonciations et des actions
suite aux actes racistes qui ont pu
avoir lieu au sein de la police
nationale
alors il ya les enquête de l'igpn mais
encore une fois elles sont elles sont
extrêmement décrié mais surtout il n'y a
pas de paroles assez forte de la part de
ce préfet l'allemand qui par exemple à
une époque lors des manifestations
dédiées les jaunes par les deux camps et
disait à une citoyens qui n'étaient pas
dans le même camp que cette femme c'est
inacceptable de la part d'un préfet de
par les deux camps donc il a raison de
recadrer de dire que la police est une
institution et on ne peut pas dire la
police est raciste c'est faux mais ce
qui moi vous pose problème et qui nous
pose problème à tous et c'est pour ça
que il ya autant de monde aujourd'hui
devant le parvis du palais de justice
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de dénonciation
assez forte de la part du ministre du
préfet ou même du président de la
république de ces dysfonctionnements qui
sont graves parce que ils remettent en
cause la confiance qu'ont les français
dans la police et il est temps d'arrêter
on ne peut pas faire de la police un
ennemi de l'intérieur
on ne peut pas entendre tous les flics
sont des [ __ ] all cops are bastards
c'est faux la police elle doit être
respectée mais pour ça elle doit montrer
du respect et elle doit surtout être
exemplaire et aujourd'hui on a tout sur
l'exemplarité à la tête de l'état on a
tout sauf l'exemplarité dans la façon
dont est gérée en fait cette institution
donc c'est ça qui est dangereux et
extrêmement grave alexis bollart vous
enviez étonné tout à l'heure quand j'ai
prononcé le mot émeute en tout cas je
vous posais la question de la
possibilité que ça que c'est cette issue
là on se souvient quand même des
les épisodes dramatiques de villiers le
bel en 2005 où deux jeunes hommes
avaient trouvé la mort dans ce fameux
générateur électrique save et crée les
émeutes dont on se souvient situation
vous l'avez dit vous-même tendue en
france avec une situation économique
très compliqué ce qu'on doit craindre
une escalade dans les prochains temps
dans notre pays est ce que vous la
craignais oui et je suis pas le seul
pour avoir parlé avec des syndicalistes
policiers ils sont très conscients que
l'automne risque d'être particulièrement
agitée 11% de récession économique
beaucoup de chômeurs de nouveaux
chômeurs qui vont arriver un climat
mondial qui est celui de la contestation
mais ça depuis 2010 9 déjà dix pays qui
étaient dans la rue contre leurs élites
corrompues deux ans de manifestations
tous les samedis de gilet jaune qui
rappelez-vous ont manifesté pour et bien
sauver le pouvoir d'achat éviter le
déclassement contre la taxe carbone est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on entend la
petite musique du groupe d'économistes
mis en place par le président de la
république
et bien c'est le retour de la taxe
carbone c'est travailler plus et être
payés - le chantage en fait aux salaires
en disant vous allez être obligés d'être
payés moins pour garder votre emploi
donc le chantage à l'emploi
tout est là toutes les recettes en fait
les ingrédients pour une déflagration
sociale d'une ampleur inédite est
malheureusement encore une fois si vous
regardez en haut à l'elysée à matignon
et ailleurs on n'a pas l'impression
d'une volonté de concorde mais plutôt
d'une volonté d'affrontements qui est la
même en fait depuis deux ans donc je
suis extrêmement inquiet je suis pas le
seul au sein de la police également les
gens sont inquiets de ce qui pourrait se
passer je pense que l'été va être chaud
il va falloir être vigilant sur cette
récession énorme qui arrive et que bien
septembre risque d'être un mois noir en
termes de contestation sociale
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
cofondateur du monde moderne d'avoir été
avec nous et on en vient la situation
aux états unis va-t-il y avoir une
huitième nuit consécutive 2 heures et ce
un peu plus d'une semaine après la mort
de georges floyd un afro américain
décédé 24 mai au cours d'une
interpellation policière à minneapolis
ses funérailles sont prévues mardi
prochain clémence pital
des vitrines saccagées des poubelles
incendiées c'est une nouvelle nuit sous
tension qui a marqué new york alors
qu'un couvre feu a été instauré dans
plusieurs grandes villes américaines en
réponse aux manifestations violentes qui
ont eu lieu dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi le maire de new york annonce un
couvre feu prolongé de trois heures dès
ce mardi la mort de georges floyd tué
par un policier à choquer des millions
d'américains
quelques heures plus tôt à washington
donald trump a encore menacé de déployer
les forces armées
si des scènes de pillage des modes comme
celle de ce week-end devait se répéter
si une ville ou un état refuse de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
défendre la vie et les biens de ses
habitants alors je déploierai l'armée
des états unis et je résoudrai
rapidement le problème à leur place
treize mille soldats de la garde
nationale sont actuellement mobilisées à
travers le pays
sur le terrain médico légal la
contestation est également palpable
après une première autopsie contestée
par la famille un deuxième examen
indépendant montre que le décès serait
lié à une asphyxie due à la pression
exercée sur le cou de la victime
l'analyse officielle avait conclu à un
arrêt cardiaque comme causes du décès ce
n'est pas seulement le genou sur le coup
de georges qui a causé sa mort mais
c'est également le poids des deux autres
officiers sur son dos ils ont non
seulement empêcher l'afflux de sang dans
son cerveau mais aussi le flux d'air
dans ses poumons
ceci rend tous les agents présents sur
les lieux pénalement responsable et sans
aucun doute civilement responsable
l'histoire de georges floyd a ému
l'amérique
le frère de la victime s'est rendue ce
lundi sur le lieu de l'arrestation et de
la mort de son frère à minneapolis
lors de ce moment de recueillement
terrance floyd a exhorté les
manifestants à mettre fin aux violences
je comprends que vous soyez tous
bouleversés comme ça a déjà été dit je
ne veux pas que vous soyez aussi
bouleversée que moi donc si je ne
m'énerve pas si je ne fais rien exploser
si je ne salit pas ma communauté
alors qu'est ce que vous devez faire
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous ne devez rien faire parce que ça ne
fera jamais revenir mon frère sur place
c'est toujours le choc et
l'incompréhension
les habitants de minneapolis sont
révoltés par la violence de
l'arrestation
nous avons tous vu la vidéo nous savons
tous qu'ils savaient très bien ce qu'ils
faisaient
nous savons tous que c'était une
décision consciente c'était quoi ça neuf
minutes de vidéo où on voit les
policiers impassible pendant que le type
meurt lentement mais enfin ne vois pas
d'autre issue pour eux qu'une poursuite
en justice c'est la même rengaine qui se
répète encore et encore peu importe ce
qu'on fait c'est accablant
point barre regardez ça c'est historique
c'est comme l'histoire son lit dans les
livres pas seulement aux états unis mais
pour le monde entier
ici c'est la mecque de la violence c'est
ici qu'on se trouve les afro américains
ne représentent que 13% de la population
des états unis ils ont pourtant trois
fois plus de chances de se faire arrêter
par la police
alors que la profession est pointé du
doigt par les protestataires
des centaines de policiers de plusieurs
villes américaines ont posé un genou à
terre pour marquer leur soutien aux
manifestants
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec caleb un mot pas un
correspondant verte et aux etats unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soit bonsoir calais bat pas on vous
retrouve régulièrement en ce moment pour
nous commente et donc la situation aux
états unis quels sont les développements
de la journée
nous avons eu une nuit de plus où il ya
eu beaucoup d'affrontements de pillages
à new york un magasin de macy's et
d'autres boutiques bien connu à
manhattan ont été envahies par des
manifestants il ya beaucoup de conflits
de combats dans les rues même si la
déclaration d'un couvre-feu qui est
beaucoup d'arrestations
il ya eu beaucoup d'action dans les rues
de washington
aadaissé et on a des rapports de tout le
pays mais en tout cas les manifestations
continuent et la colère est la manade
dans la communauté afro américaine
cependant il semble qu'on demande de
plus en plus aux manifestants 4e et
pacifique qui ait moins de problèmes et
de dégâts alors l'onu a réagi
aujourd'hui à travers 100 au
commissariat la pandémie et les
manifestations met en évidence les
discriminations raciales en des milk
michael jordan le basketteur qui est
sorti de sa réserve a dit un petit peu
la même chose racisme en crée notamment
de la police aux états unis partagez
vous ce constat vous qui êtes
journaliste sur place ne fait aucun
doute les états unis sont un pays très
divisé la communauté afro américaine a
subi tant d'années de discrimination à
vue
tant de fois des membres de la
communauté tués a justement par les
forces de police et ces personnes les
personnes qu'ils ont tuées ou non rien
subi un retour donc il ya beaucoup de
colère mais effectivement il ya la
pandémie qui sera ajouté à cela donald
trump a eu une approche très différente
en fonction des états n'y a pas eu
d'unification de politique commune les
etats unis sont de plus en plus polarisé
en tant que pays il ya différentes
communautés différentes régions avec
différentes valeurs et c'est très clair
si l'on regarde le développement de la
société américaine notamment si on
regarde la réponse du président à cette
crise justement le président qui
définitivement se range du côté il l'a
dit un de l'ordre est ce que c'est une
bonne stratégie aujourd'hui alors que le
pays souffre souffrent évidemment de
cette grosse crise économique d'un
chômage terrible et évidemment récemment
donc ces émeutes est ce que c'est le bon
choix fait par le président américain
qui on le rappelle est en campagne
présidentielle non non ce n'est pas le
bon choix mais cela plaît aux personnes
que donald trump et c'est le courtiser
pour les élections à venir
la base de l'électorat de donald trump
ce sont des gens qui habitent ce
temps-là rospez des personnes plus âgées
qui ont l'impression que le pays se
désagrège
ils sont impressionnés par les paroles
ferme de donald trump cela ne fait aucun
doute
donald trump je propose d'interdire le
mouvement antifa il annonce que dès que
le piège commencera épouse lisible
soldats pour ouvrir le feu c'est une
situation très délicate mais cela plaît
a donc à son électorat beaucoup de
personnes en tout cas critiques donald
trump pour sa séance photo qui l'a
organisé devant l'église saint john qui
a été
endommagée par les manifestants des
manifestants ont subi des tirs de gaz
lacrymogène afin qu'ils puissent se
rendre à une séance photo devant cette
église obtenant une bible à la main et
cela n'est pas du tout fédérateur aussi
des états unis qui est impulsif bonne
blague mais en tout cas des personnes
décapita ohio en pâtit vallier dans le
bus can sing cela et c'est eux que
donald trump et celle de courtiser il
essaie de leur montrer qu'ils essayent
de défendre l'amérique qu'il voit
disparaître devant leurs yeux il est en
défense de l'or et le temps défense de
la religion c'est le dernier espoir d'un
pays en sièges pour donald trump ils
n'essayent pas de calmer la situation
ils essaient d'acquérir plus de votes
dans les régions importantes pour lui la
mort de joseph haydn est ce qu'on peut
dire que c'est la goutte qui a fait
déborder l'eau du vase est ce que le
pays
aujourd'hui les états unis sont
clairement un tournant à une étape
importante le monde sera plus le même
désormais la première c'est que
l'attitude du grand public a beaucoup
changé
l'idée que la police a toujours raison
qu'il faut leur faire confiance qui sont
tout à fait comme ce qu'on voit à la
télévision où des héros qui ont entravé
par des libertaires qui les empêchent
d'attraper les méchants tout ça c'est
oublier avant les militants et noir les
militants gauchistes avec mme été
différente
mais aujourd'hui dans les sections les
plus libérales de la société le coût de
personnes pense qu'effectivement il ya
des quais est raciste
dans la police et l'idée qu'il faut
faire confiance à la police
et ça paie aujourd'hui mais je pense que
l'une des autres clé c'est la pandémie
beaucoup de personnes ont perdu leur
emploi sont passés chez elles ne peuvent
pas vivre leur vie normale
ces personnes voit ces images sont
anxieuses du fait des difficultés
économiques et elles ont le temps et la
motivation pour sortir et manifester
donc le facteur économique est elle sous
jacent mais très présent et il ya de
plus une anxiété et une ferveur causés
par tous ces difficultés certaines
images peuvent choquer effectivement
depuis la france on voit des camions de
police poncet dans la foule on a vu ça
ce week-end
question claire à ce que la démocratie
est en danger
aux etats unis beaucoup de personnes se
posent la question
donald trump s'est réfugié dans un
bunker sous la maison blanche
on a appelé l'armée beaucoup de
manifestants sont morts des protestants
ce dernier restant sont morts par
exemple un des braqueurs dans le
cantique y ait des morts à des trolls et
nous n'avons pas encore de décombres ne
sont pas combien de manifestants sont
morts les médias ne suivent pas la
situation en tout cas beaucoup en tout
cas certains sont morts l'armée est
déployée nous avons vu des hélicoptères
de l'armée dans les rues de washington
dc
hier soir télécopie terre qui volaient
très bas pour essayer de disperser la
foule
donc effectivement on dirait que c'est
une situation qui ressemble à la prise
ou un coup d'état la prise du pouvoir
par l'armée cela ressemble beaucoup aux
images qu'on peut voir d'autres pays où
cela s est passé le président et lui dit
qu'il va reprendre le contrôle de la
situation il utilise un langage de
domination me dit qu'il va dominer les
manifestants c'est exactement ce que
cela dure rihanna est en tout cas ce
sont les termes qui l'utilisent
et effectivement beaucoup de personnes
demandent à ce qu'il soit chassé ne sont
pas beaucoup de personnes beaucoup de
manifestants ne manifestent plus contre
la police mais plutôt contre donald
trump pour eux de me tromper le symbole
de toutes ces choses outrageante et les
démocrates ont de meilleurs sondages et
acquiert de plus en plus de soutiens
donc je vois comment on pourrait le voir
de cette façon si mais en tout cas la
campagne sera en les élections seront en
levant même s'il y aura pas une campagne
très importante
en tout cas les les bases de la
démocratie ne sommes pas encore être
détruite
aux etats unis effectivement certains
signes à l'horizon laisse penser qu'on
pourrait être nerveux merci caleb
beaupain correspondant rt aux états unis
d'avoir été avec nous restez avec nous
donc quelques instants nous parlerons du
professeur raoul t de la chloroquine
dans une nouvelle vidéo l'infectiologue
marseillais répond à ses détracteurs une
nouvelle fois et a rappelé son parcours
qui je suis fait rêver à peu près
n'importe qui puis nous parlerons du
lancement du stop kovy de l'application
qui permet d'informer des personnes qui
sont entrées en contact rapproché avec
un positif au kovy 19 rester là
[Musique]
parce que c'est la question du jour
dans quel monde on a envie de vivre
il faut qu'on chante le terrain peu
c'est la seule façon de proposer une
alternative
je pense en réalité qu'on va de plus en
plus à l'est vers le télétravail au
salon auto que ça du 1er au 13 avril à
2020 83% des entreprises avaient entre
10 % et plus de 80% de leurs
collaborateurs en télétravail
fantastique opportunité et on a utilisé
pour ça un seul outil qu'est la
visioconférence
il ya des bouquins fait nîmes en plus
efficace le numérique est il le grand
gagnant de la crise du convive 19 c sur
que facebook et google ainsi qu amazon
qui d'un point de vue politique a tout
révolutionné sont pour l'instant les
grands gagnants de cette ligue
en revanche nos libertés sont les
grandes perdantes c'est l'application
d'un modèle mais c'est l'application
d'un modèle qui n'est pas le nôtre est
le problème il vient de là
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à lévis mais quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'on voit des beaucoup de des
masques des matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles courent transformé après
la pandémie la crise maintenant à fait
bien comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier
des banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas seulement d'elle même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france 20h30
heure française didier raoul jet à
nouveau un pavé dans la mare dans une
nouvelle vidéo publiée aujourd'hui sur
sa chaîne youtube le directeur de l'irs
je suis méditerranée infections
marseille a tenu à défendre son parcours
en se qualifiant le site de star des
maladies infectieuses après avoir jugé
il ya quelques jours de foire aux la
publication parue dans la revue
seul un set discrédite ces travaux je
vous propose de l'écouter il y a une
haine des vraies élites c'est nous on va
vite et donc les gens d'ailleurs
pourquoi les élites vous aime pas les
hélices qui n'aime pas c'est eux qui
n'est pas assez vite
moi je suis une star des maladies
infectieuses j'ai tout lu j'ai aperçu ce
qui fait rêver à peu près n'importe qui
aussi bien fonctions officielles j'étais
plus jeune président d'université de
france le club ailleurs médecin le
produit le plus jeune de tous les bêtes
de tous les professeurs la classe
exceptionnelle professeur le plus ancien
dans le grade le plus élevé de tous pays
et les teams
j'ai tout eu dans ma vie donc si vous
laissez moi les 10 mai ce pays de temps
en temps à des crises dans cas il veut
décapité son élite est pas révolution a
décapité la boisier l'inserm en 1981
décapiter les cinq médecins les plus
célèbres de france et pour en parler
nous sommes avec laurent giacomelli
parole du rassemblement national bonsoir
laurent jack o bélie merci d'être avec
nous en direct quand vous entendez cette
défense peut-être un petit peu maladroit
de vous en laisse et jugez vous même de
didier raoul qui se dit voilà j'ai tout
eu j'ai tout fait bref est ce que didier
raoult a pris la grosse tête ou tout
simplement il est assez malin il se
place sur une défense voilà anti système
anti élites quelle est votre réaction
moi ma réaction c'est de dire c'est
quand même dommage que le professeur out
en soi à devoir se justifier en étalant
son cv sur youtube
le professeur out et c'est un fait un
des plus grands spécialistes dans son
domaine et on a beaucoup de lachamp
beaucoup de chance pardon parce que ce
spécialiste est français et de le voir
aujourd'hui obligé
d'énumérer tous ses titres tous ses
faits de gloire c'est un peu triste
parce que s'il le fait c'est qu'il a été
traîné dans la boue par des laboratoires
par certains ministres qui l'ont traité
comme un hurluberlu comme un charlatan
qui ne savait pas de quoi il parlait je
vais vous dire ce qui est étonnant c'est
pas la manière dont il parle on a
l'habitude de sa faconde et de son style
un peu particulier non ce qui est
étonnant c'est ce qui est révoltant
c'est que dans notre pays on a tout fait
à l'envers quand on a un didier rahout
en france qui préconise un traitement
contre le corps un navire russe qui est
une terrible pandémie
le premier réflexe ça doit être de dire
on va mener une étude pour savoir si la
raison et s'il a tort on va lui donner
tous les moyens pour le faire et on
espère qu'on va trouver au plus vite la
bonne solution
et bien en france on a fait l'inversé
texte du gouvernement on a dit non il
faut pas l'écouter on ne fera pas les
cud et puis après on va la faire mais au
niveau européen et là pour le coup ça a
été vraiment foireux parce que l'étude
de discovery n'aura jamais lieu
et puis après on a dit pis que pendre de
lui mais on n'a jamais fait d'études
officielles nationales en france pour
savoir si l'hydroxyde chloroquine plus
un autre médicament pouvait empêcher
l'évolution du virus en tout début de
contamination est bien le vrai problème
est le vrai scandale
il est la salle et moi je suis dans les
bouches du rhône j'habite à l'eau juste
à côté de marseille eh ben je connais
des personnes qui ont été malades qui
ont utilisé le traitement du professeur
à vous et qui ont été mieux en quelques
jours ma crainte c'est qu'on ne sache
jamais vraiment et scientifiquement si
c'était efficace et qu'on ne le sera
peut-être même pas après la fin de
l'épidémie
c'est là le gouvernement a failli à
l'orangé comédie quand il dit didier
rahout c'est pas justement vos on a bien
compris que quand il parle de système
vous dit non mais le fond du débat il
est ailleurs il est sur la chloroquine
mai mais quand même ça revient ces
histoires d'élite il ya une heure
une haine des vraies élites la vraie vie
tu sais nous en réalité si ce
scientifique reconnue a besoin d'aller
sur ce terrain là c'est que peut-être
qu'il pense qu'il ya un fond vérité
justement sur l' usage de ces
chloroquine et que ça ne se soit pas
fait est ce que il a justement de france
qui s'opposent dans cette histoire
notamment
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait deux france
qui se posent il y à 35 incompétents qui
ne savent rien faire au gouvernement
qu'ils ne comprennent pas la france
réelle et qu'ils n'écoutent pas à la
france réelle quand on a un professeur
round en france on écoute plutôt que
d'écouter une incapable comme madame
busin ou un incompétent comme monsieur
vers en voilà la vraie la réalité et
c'est vrai en économie c'est vrai dans
tous les domaines c'est vrai en culture
c'est vrai en terme de sécurité
on n'a jamais accumulé un aussi grand
nombre de bâtera le gouvernement qui
refuse d'écouter ce qu'ils savent pillon
qui les toise qui les regardent de haut
plein d'arrogance plein de certitudes
alors que concrètement ils ne savent pas
faire je comprends que ça énerve le
professeur out
je comprends que ça énerve les français
de voir ces gens obtus imaginez il aura
fallu trois mois pour qu'il trouve des
masques trois mois qu'ils trouvent des
tests de seconde pour qu'ils arrêtent
l'hydroxyde chloroquine après une étude
dont maintenant tout le monde dit
qu'elle était pipeau c'est quand même
très grave et la colère des professeurs
out
elle fait écho à la colère des français
de ce qu'ils vivent au quotidien dans
cette étude sur 27 étaient pipeau alors
c'est vrai qu'ils ont aujourd'hui fait
un petit air à tous mais sur une erreur
de codage c'est un petit peu technique
mais vous remettez en cause justement
cette étude cette revue qui est quand
même reconnu moi je ne suis pas médecin
1 j'ai lu l'étude mais je ne sais pas en
tirer personnellement des conclusions
mais je vois des médecins qui montre des
des invraisemblances
déclare plus de morts en australie qu'il
y en a eu les statistiques sont
tellement parfaite que ce n'est pas
crédible
et apparemment la directrice commerciale
de l'institut qui a donné les données à
7 à cette revue landes 7 serait en fait
un fake
ce serait une star du porno franchement
est-ce que c'est sérieux est-ce que là
on est dans le sérieux et est ce que le
gouvernement est monsieur vers ans
n'aurait pas dû prendre au moins
quelques jours pour étudier cette étude
et pour dire après si elle valait le
coup ou pas dans l'île se sont
précipités pour arbitrer l'hydroxyde
rockin et un jour on devra comprendre
pourquoi
hamon dernière question sur le
déconfinement c'est aujourd'hui donc le
grand stade 2 les restaurants les bars
qui rouvre l'appliquent au vide qui est
en marche également qui est en
fonctionnement votre réaction c'est une
bonne chose ou une mauvaise chose
décidément ils seront en retard sur tout
l'appui que lui devait arriver au moment
où à nous annoncer la fin de l'épidémie
bon j'espère que ces gens là n'auront
jamais à gérer une pénurie alimentaire
ou une guerre pour la france parce que
vraiment ils ont fait montre d'un
compétences non aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus qu'un danger cette appli un danger
sur les données personnelles danger sur
le traçage des individus ce serait
difficile de croire que c'est un atout
d'abord c'est volontaire très peu de
gens vont télécharger cette appli et
puis une fois encore pourquoi n'at-on
pas fait à ce moment-là si c'était
efficace il ya trois mois quand le virus
était à son pic
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été capables de même qu'ils n'ont pas
été capables de faire une étude
européenne avec discovery sur la
chloroquine ils ont été en retard
surtout surtout surtout ils ne savent
pas appréhendé ils ne savent pas écoutés
ils ne savent pas gérer
ils ne savent qu imposer écrit après les
français on a vu les limites de cette
démarche de ce mode de gestion
merci à laurent jacot bénie par parole
du rassemblement national d'avoir été
avec nous et on vient de le dire donc la
phase 2 du déconfinement tout coïncide
avec le lancement en manque de stock co
vide cela devrait être effectif à midi
mais finalement ça a pris un petit peu
de retard l'application et d or
disponible sur le magasin d'applications
google playes un outil polémique qui
permet de tracer des personnes positives
au qu'ovide 19 utilisable sur la base du
volontariat son but est de réduire
l'impact du corps n'avait eu son
identifiant les chaînes de transmission
et si la plupart des français semble
trouver stop qu'ovide utile certains
redoutent encore l'utilisation de leurs
données personnelles côté je pense que
c'est une bonne idée et je vais essayer
de télécharger ce soir plus on prend des
mesures qui sont dites temporaire c'est
la difficulté du temporaire comme toute
législation
c'est qu'a priori ça devrait permettre
d'aller d'être plus rapide ou plus
réactif sur la détection des personnes
avec lequel vous avez été en compta que
vous ne connaissez pas je trouve que
c'est une mesure qui peut être utile et
que voilà je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
d'intérêt à la télécharger
c'est quelque chose de bien je trouve
c'est déjà ça nous aide beaucoup à
trouver si les personnes autour de nous
ils ont commis deux pas si l'on le
symptôme des symptômes ou s'ils sont
touchés par
par l'épidémie ouais je trouve ça sympa
déjà d'inventer sa est de pouvoir
utiliser ce système
je pense que j'ai pas j'ai pas envie
d'avoir que mes données soient soit
suivi par le bas par le gouvernement
quand je pense qu'un a qui vont le
télécharger parce qu'ils ont perdu qu
vide mais et sans pour autant penser
qu'on les suit avec tout donné mais il y
en a c'est clair et net qu'il a
téléchargé l'application stop covin
téléchargeable sur nos téléphones
portables alors faut-il sont méfiés ou
est ce une bonne nouvelle pour la lutte
contre le coc vide c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
débattre nous sommes avec isabelle
landreau avocate spécialiste en
nouvelles technologies bonsoir m
landreau merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france pour en débattre
donc yves buisson épidémiologistes
président du groupe coville 19 de
l'académie nationale de médecine bonsoir
à vous il va buisson merci également
d'être avec nous alors stop qu'ovide on
sait que c'est très décrié y aller pour
y aller contre quelle est votre réaction
vous yves buisson mais ma réaction c'est
que tous les moyens sont bons pour
lutter contre cette épidémie qui une
épidémie mortelle très grave et qui
n'est pas terminée donc c'est un moyen
intéressant qui va permettre de détecter
et des nouveaux cas et donc je crois
qu'il faut absolument pas s'en priver
dans la mesure bien entendu où ce moyen
respecte les droits des personnes et je
crois que des garanties suffisantes ont
été donnés dans ce sens-là l'académie
nationale de médecine a émis un
communiqué pour souligner l'intérêt réel
que cette mesure peut apporter dans la
lutte contre l'épidémie
mais en soulignant qu' il fallait bien
entendu de garantir un certain nombre de
de droit un avait donc déjà que ce rsa
repose sur le volontariat et qu'il n'y
ait pas de viol organisation est que ces
données soient détruites dès que
l'épidémie sera terminée dès qu'elles ne
sont plus nécessaires donc aucune
données nominales une donnée de vous
permettant la reconnaissance des
personnes également ne doit être stocké
donc dans ces conditions l'académie de
médecine a donné un avis tout à fait
favorables et auquel bien entendu je me
rallie qu'en pense l'avocate isabelle à
landreau bonsoir alors évidemment pour
l'avocate je suis pas du tout d'accord
je pense que cette application est les
accessoires inutiles accessoires
pourquoi parce que nous avons déjà des
fichiers existants nous avons deux
fichiers nous avons le fichier si des
qui est le système d'information de
dépistage
or nous avons lançons des résultats des
laboratoires du test cobas 19 grâce à ce
fichier sida d'autre part nous avons un
deuxième fichier qu'est le fichier
contact covic qui est essentiellement
pour le domaine médical et qui permet de
suivre d'accompagner les personnes déjà
infectées
donc il me semble que avec cet arsenal
là c'est déjà suffisant on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir une application qui va
tracer
bien sûr nous avons des crypto
identifiant qui relie un numéro de
téléphone qui nous relie à une personne
physique mais cette personne va être
tracé et elle mettait tout suivi dans
ses déplacements
donc pour moi c'est accessoire est utile
inutile pourquoi parce que c'est une
atteinte à notre liberté notre liberté
individuelle la liberté de déplacement
d'aller et de venir et je pense que l
est elle sera très limité en effet le
succès de cette application dépend du
téléchargement massif
il faut à peu près que 60% des français
téléchargent cette application pour que
ce soit vraiment efficace et il me
semble que en comparaison des pays
étrangers notamment l'australie où c'est
que 5% des personnes qui ont le
télécharger l'islande où là c'est le
plus
pourcentage 40% et bien nous je pense
que le français moyen va être réticent à
télécharger cette application puisque
c'est du traçage et donc son effet sera
limité et 800 qu'est ce que vous
répondez donc je résume en substance à
les paroles de m landreau atteinte aux
libertés
inutile on va avoir du mal à convaincre
les français qu'ils n'auront pas envie
d'être tracé qu'elle a été vous le
retour sur le terrain justement des
patients français
je voudrais leur dire que ce n'est pas
se superposent pas aux deux autres
méthodes de détection des patients qui
existent effectivement il ya les
méthodes de déclaration des tests
positifs qui existe et puis il ya le
traçage autour d'un cas qui avait que
les les groupes qui sont mis en qui sont
mis en oeuvre par autour du médecin qui
a fait le diagnostic d'un cas c'est
complémentaire puisque la personne qui
ce qui va déclarer qu'elle est infectée
par la commune 19 n'a pas forcément été
testée et elle peut être malade avoir
été diagnostiquée positive à voir même
un test négatif et être tout à fait
suspecte d'avoir la maladie
s'il déclare on va contacter des
personnes avec qui elle était en
proximité pendant une quel calcul
pendant quelques minutes
un moins d'un mètre et ces personnes
elle ne les connaît pas lorsqu'on fait
le traçage à partir du médecin ont fait
le traçage dans les personnes dans les
relations dans les personnes que l'on
connaît on sait qu'on a été en contact
on a peu on a vu monsieur machin ou
madame truc dans les classes sur les
personnes qu'on ne connaît pas donc
c'est un outil supplémentaire
complémentaire par rapport aux deux
autres méthodes de détection et je crois
que dans cette période de déconfinement
il faut se servir de tout ce qui est à
notre portée bien entendu il faut pas
faire n'importe quoi
les français sont très sont très
paranoïaque en ce qui concerne le le
traçage les libertés les
les big brother on se raconte beaucoup
d'histoires alors que tout le monde
utilise des moyens d'aider par les
réseaux sociaux ne prend aucune
précaution et c'est vrai que les gens
sont tracées ils sont tracées à leur
insu ou pas leur insu ce sont souvent
les gens s'en fichent complètement mais
ils sont tracées et alors quand il
s'agit d'organiser quelque chose pour la
santé pour la santé publique alors là a
alors là on fait appel aux libertés
individuelles et on se souvient quand on
est français qu'il faut se bagarrer pour
défendre ses libertés
c'est c'est complètement à côté de la
plaque je crois qu'il faut se souvenir
qu'on a affaire à une épidémie qui est
extrêmement dangereuse qui a tué
beaucoup de monde et qui n'a pas fini de
tuer et pour laquelle il faut se donner
absolument tous les moyens pour en venir
à bout
isabelle andro vous voyez sourire en a
laissé terminer à l'argumentaire des
buissons voilà c'est vrai que beaucoup
de français un livre leur vie sur les
réseaux sociaux et quand il s'agit de la
santé publique et bien on se trouve un
petit peu méfiant qu'est ce que vous
répondez oui alors je trouve que on agit
sur la crainte de la résurgence et elle
n'est pas là pourquoi parce que les
chiffres récents démontrent qu'il n'ya
pas cette résurgence
donc on agit vraiment en prévention et
comme l'a souligné monsieur buisson
l'application va pas démontré que vous
est contaminé c'est une suspicion de
rencontres avec des gens contaminés donc
on va tracer des gens pour une suspicion
de contamination donc on est vraiment en
amont donc pour moi évidemment c'est
complètement une entrave à la liberté
d'aller et venir et les données seront
stockées cette évidence est un serveur
centralisé qu'elle gérait pas leur
autorité de santé
le parlement européen avait été contre
cette architecture en disant attention
ça peut générer des failles plus que des
serveurs décentralisés
ce n'a pas été suivi donc évidemment il
ya un risque
il ya un risque sur nos libertés
individuelles et payer un risque aussi
sur le fait que ce traçage
bien sûr c'est pour la sécurité
sanitaire et nous vie à tous et j'en
conviens mais est-ce que ça va pas faire
apprécier
donc est ce que finalement on comptera
pas dans une société de surveillance
les cas pieds devant et puis avec
docilement le citoyen français va
s'habituer
parce que finalement on a cette excuse
bien sûr de sauver des vies je pense
qu'on a des outils suffisants qui ont
fait leurs preuves et aussi on a le
maillage des médecins de ville français
dont comptons sur l'existant pourquoi
ajouter une application de plus qui en
plus ont fait le jeu des pirates parce
qu'on va rémunérer des pirates à hauteur
de 2000 euros pour casser les failles
ainsi de suite donc moi je crains qu'on
rentre dans une société de surveillance
et que docilement le français soit
endormi par cette application parce que
évidemment il faut sauver des vies alors
il ya plusieurs choses aillent vite
selon la société de surveillance mais il
ya quand même quelque chose d'important
qui a été soulevée sur lequel vous ne
semblez pas d'accord isabelle andro bon
qui n'est pas médecin bien sûr mais
comme personne ne l'est en tout cas à
part vous ni moi en tout cas
nous affirmons là que c'est peut-être
trop tard en fait que l'épidémie est en
train de marquer clairement le pas
aisément les chiffres sont tombés 107
morts de plus en france mardi la baisse
qui se poursuit en réanimation
vous vous pensez qu'on va vraiment en
avoir besoin que ce n'est pas un petit
peu tard tout s'est mis en place
aujourd'hui on s'éteint c'est un très
mauvais argument parce que effectivement
l'épidémie il faut s'en réjouir et sur
la fin elle est sur la fin mais on a
encore depuis ces dernières semaines on
a eu 109 foyer ce qu'on appelle des
clusters qui se sucrent disséminés sur
le sol français
à partir de ces foyers qui ont été
identifiés par d'autres méthodes bien
entendu on a pu les on a pu les
circonscrire parce qu'ils ont été
repérés très précocement
ça veut dire pourra ça veut dire que le
virus continue de circuler sans doute à
bas bruit mais ils continuent de
circuler il va continuer de circuler
encore sans doute pendant plusieurs
semaines donc dire que cette méthode
défendre la méthode du stop qu'ovide
c'est
prendre argument de pour sauver des vies
bien oui c'est pour sauver des vies ce
n'est pas une excuse
c'est un objectif c'est notre fierté
même de vouloir sauver des vies et même
si on ne sauve qu'une seule vie grâce à
ce système
eh bien il faudra s'en réjouir je crois
qu'avec ce système bien entendu moi je
ne suis pas pour qu'on soit tous fliqués
ont horreur de ça je suis français comme
tout le monde et j'aime pas ça mais là
il ya des garanties et je vois pas quel
serait l'intérêt encore une fois pour le
gouvernement pour le nc qui de de
colliger des données qu'ils sont des
données anonymes pour savoir qu'intel a
eu le qu'ovide franchement mais qui ça
peut intéresser
je crois qu'il sait la queue on tombe un
peu dans la paranoïa
d'autre part ce système va va nous
servir parce que s'il fait preuve d'une
certaine efficacité
il y aura d'autres épidémies et c'était
essais des moyens modernes maintenant
dont il faut se doter
bien sûr il ya le port du masque 1 le
muc était complètement inconnue dans nos
dans nos régions occidentales qui
maintenant va sûrement laisser une
habitude très utile lorsqu'on aura une
épidémie d'infections par voie
respiratoire et bien le le le traçage
je ne sais pas je n'aime pas le vôtre a
sagement enfin disons l'identification
par smartphone peut être un moyen qui
laissera un outil utile pour lutter
contre les épidémies et je crois qu'il
faut pas s'en priver
aussant félicité on a compris le message
et buissons le mot de la fin très
rapidement s'il vous plaît et isabelle
andro professeur glisse en faillite vie
sont parlés voilà quel est l'intérêt du
gouvernement vous allez certainement
répondre très rapidement s'il vous plaît
monsieur buisson profession buisson a
fait la preuve que justement
l'application est inutile puisque des
clusters ont été identifiés sans cette
application donc nous avons la
possibilité d'isoler les cas contaminés
sans cette application dont en effet la
preuve a été faite par professeur je
vous en remercie cette annonce est
l'intérêt du gouvernement à garder les
données parce que il ya des français qui
se posent les questions
les données de nenê données peuvent être
gardées bien sûr il va falloir vérifier
que l soit
c'est à la fin de l'épidémie et on a
bien sûr la clean un acte neil lane sea
pour assurer cette mission là mais il se
peut aussi que les français réagissent
et demandent des droits c'est déjà
envisagé dans tous les avis publiés
notamment de l'académie du professeur et
aussi de l'académie scientifique il est
envisagé que les citoyens saisissent et
ses autorités et demande l'effacement et
on a même prévu une indemnisation
donc il ya quand même des risques merci
merci on n'aura pas eu la réponse sur
l'intérêt du gouvernement mais ça sera
l'objet d'un prochain débat merci en
tout cas tous les deux
isabelle android lui sont d'avoir
accepté de débattre en direct sur notre
antenne dans quelques instants rester
avec nous direction les états unis après
une nouvelle nuit de violence suite à la
mort de georges floyd le couvre-feu à
new york est prolongée jusqu'à dimanche
après des émeutes et puis nous
reviendrons sur la phase ii du gouffre
de déconfinement dans l'hexagone bars et
restaurants sont ouverts sous conditions
aujourd'hui pour le plus grand bonheur
des français
[Musique]
l'afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'hérault pour les
états unis quelle stratégie vous avez
déployés dans le sud kivu pour limiter
la propagation du virus on a proposé à
ce qu'est le confinement puisse être
sélectif est concerné seulement des
personnes âgées à haut risque de
complication pour sensibiliser la
population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'elle venait de sortir d'une
épidémie à ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
tutorat
si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
corona
ça pourrait être très très difficile
pour nous
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe
c'est à dire à côté
cata strophe hague il ya un tournant
mais on re se remet à vivre mais dans
une autre direction c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire de l'humanité que
pour sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vous ça dépend
quelle valeur on attribue à la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie relève
bien fait mais si on considère que
maintenant il va y avoir des
catastrophes même individuel avec cette
décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon intronisation
dans la crise ducobu 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
qui responsables du fisc alors que l'on
aime s recommandait le port du masque
par les populations la parole publique a
longtemps menti sur sa nécessité pour ne
pas avouer la triste absence du stock
requis
la décision de confinement s'imposait
compte-tenu du manque de matériel
permettant d'autres solutions mais en
freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise l'économie l'état ne pourra
plus être l'état providence que nous
avons que pour anne aura été cimetière
de certaines espérances en pensant que
le progrès faisait de nous des hommes
dieu et que les technocrates avait les
clés du monde demain des conséquences de
la crise oblige à repenser nos modèles
la découverte du télétravail l'intérêt
de consommer des produits locaux le
besoin de solidarité vont faire évoluer
une population qui a découvert qu'elle
était mortel
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si seul interdit d'interdire
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale
quel rôle doit selon vont jouer à levin
et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans les faits
les villes tout comme les états ils
étaient pas préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront rassembler les îles comment est
ce qu'elles peuvent transformer après la
pandémie la crise maintenant à fait bien
comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier des
banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle n'est pas seulement d'elle-même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 2 juin
une mobilisation interdite par la
préfecture de police en ce moment même
devant le tribunal judiciaire de paris
rassemblement en hommage à adama traoré
jeune homme décédé en 2016 lors d'une
interpellation
le comité de soutien à la famille
d'amara traoré veut également dénoncer
les violences policières et soutenir les
manifestants américains mobilisés depuis
la mort de giorgio floride
et justement aux etats-unis nouvelle
miss violence une semaine après la mort
de cet afro américain lors d'une
interpellation policière
donald trump menace de déployer l'armée
pour éteindre des protestations qui
selon l'onu met en évidence des
discriminations raciales endémique
premier jour du retour à la vie presque
normale coup d'envoi aujourd'hui de la
phase 2 du déconfinement en france fin
de la règle des 100 km retour en classe
des lycéens réouverture des restaurants
en zone verte et des terrasses en zone
orange mise à disposition également de
l'apli controversé stop covit sur le
magasin d'applications google plaît
[Musique]
à distance et sans palpation durant la
crise du coronavirus la consultation des
médecins par écran interposé a explosé
depuis le mois de mars un million de
téléconsultation lieu chaque semaine
contre 60 milles sur toute l'année 2019
selon l'assurance maladie
le ministre de la santé olivier verrey y
voit même une façon de mettre fin aux
déserts médicaux
[Musique]
l'état signe le prêt garanti de 5
milliards d'euros bruno le maire
recevait ce matin vers 6 les syndicats
de renault son président jean dominique
senard et les élus locaux
quatre jours après l annonce du plan de
restructuration l'état obtenu les
garanties sociales qui souhaitent de la
part du constructeur automobile
si l'avenir du site de maubeuge semble
s'éclaircir les salariés de choisy le
roi dont la fermeture a été annoncée
sont eux en grève
un rassemblement donc en mémoire d'adama
traoré interdit par la préfecture de
police à paris en ce moment même et
manifestation organisée devant le
tribunal judiciaire par le comité de
soutien à la famille jaune à mort lors
d'une interpellation en juillet 2016 et
contre les violences policières
mobilisation qui n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune déclaration préalable selon la
préfecture de police
on l'a appris un peu plus tôt tout à
l'heure une contre-expertise médicale
indépendante réalisée à la demande des
proches du jeune homme valide
l'asphyxient par le placage centrale et
contredit ainsi la dernière expertise
judiciaire disculpant les gendarmes
et pour en parler nous retrouvons en
direct sur place où se trouve la
manifestation devant le tribunal notre
reporter thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas
comment se déroule cette manifestation
quelle est l'atmosphère sur place
écoutez stéphanie ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'il ya énormément de monde
qui a répondu à cet appel plusieurs
milliers de personnes qui étaient
d'abord dans un premier temps réunis sur
le parvis du tribunal de paris et qui
est désormais sur le boulevard des
maréchaux vous aurez peut-être du mal à
les apercevoir sur ces images ils sont
derrière les camions de crs ils sont
très nombreux massé ici pour faire
entendre leurs revendications plusieurs
slogans ont été scandés à de nombreuses
reprises depuis le début de cette
manifestation d'abord il ya justice pour
adama car vous le savez c'est le
collectif la vérité pour adama qui est à
l'origine de ce rassemblement avec
notamment à sa traoré la soeur damas qui
a lancé cet appel au rassemblement elle
a pris la parole à de nombreuses
reprises et elle se trouve en tête de ce
cortège donc composé de plusieurs
milliers de personnes sur les pancartes
également on peut apercevoir des black
clouds matters en référence évidemment à
la situation aux états unis
et voilà donc ce qui compose cette
manifestation où la plupart des
participants sont des participants à ces
jeunes et qui ont donc répondu de façon
très nombreuses à cet appel à la
mobilisation mobilisation qui est
interdite puisque cet après midi la
préfecture de police de paris a publié
un communiqué dans lequel elle explique
que les rassemblements de plus de dix
personnes sont toujours interdits dans
la capitale et bien en dépit donc de
cette interdiction il ya du monde ici et
vous le voyez les forces de l'ordre sont
présentes à proximité du cortège mais
pour tout vous dire malgré des slogans
qui sont parfois hostiles aux forces de
l'ordre l'ambiance est tout à fait
pacifique il n'y a eu aucun débordement
pour le moment a dénombré ici où la
plupart des manifestants même si
évidemment là le respect des gestes
barrière est un peu compliqué vous
l'imaginez bien la plupart portent tout
de même des masques pour se protéger en
cette période de crise sanitaire
merci thomas bonnet
et en direct donc de cette manifestation
parisienne met il pas novice président
du groupe à la fille à l'assemblée
nationale député du val-de-marne était
présente justement ce rassemblement un
peu plus tôt écouter pour soutenir ça
traoré sa famille pour demander la
justice et la vérité sur la mort d'adama
et aussi pour dire avec un nombre
absolument impressionnant de personnes
que nous ne voulons plus de certaines
pratiques qui sont interdites dans
d'autres pays mais qui ne sont pas
interdites en france notamment le
placage centrale qui est responsable de
la 6e' d'adama traoré en tout cas c'est
la suspicion qui est c'est ce que
confirment des analyses qui ont été
faites par la famille de la victime
c'est ce qui est arrivé malheureusement
à beaucoup d'autres jeunes la police
doit être républicaine ça doit être un
service public c'est inacceptable c'est
abominable de voir les violences
policières que nous avons dans notre
pays aujourd'hui ça doit changer je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'on est très
nombreux et nombreuses à être là
aujourd'hui vous rendez compte qu'en
france on a un nombre des borniers
absolument incroyable justement du fait
des ordres qui sont donnés à la police
le préfet l'allemand est un préfet
violent il a décidé d'interdire cette
manifestation nous sommes nombreux et
nombreuses parce que cette manifestation
est juste qu'elle doit se tenir et que
nous avons le droit de nous rassembler
pour demander collectivement la justice
parce que sans justice il n'y a pas tué
mais le préfet de police de paris didier
lallement lui a adressé son soutien aux
policiers face aux accusations de
violence et de racisme écoutez sa
réponse pour les citoyens français que
nous sommes une accusation ne suffit pas
à faire une vérité la police de
l'agglomération parisienne n'est ni
violente ni raciste elle agit dans le
cadre du droit pour la liberté de tous
je ne laisserai pas salir une
institution dont le rôle dans les grands
moments de l'histoire de ce pays a été
essentielle il n'y a pas de race dans la
police pas plus que de racisées ou de
presseur raciste il ya des
fonctionnaires qui s'engage pour la
liberté l'égalité et la fraternité
et cela au quotidien et alors que les
manifestations se poursuivent aux états
unis donald rome ne semble pas vouloir
leur donner raison
le président américain est très critiqué
pour sa gestion de la crise du pays les
explications avec valentin carpentier
l'image est lourde de sens bible à la
main donald trump a voulu répondre aux
tensions qui touche les états unis après
la mort de georges floyd annonçant
vouloir rendre la grandeur à son pays le
président américain surtout était la
cible de critiques en cause la
dispersion violente de manifestants
devant la maison blanche pour permettre
cette séance photo une démarche qui nous
prend pas et qui révoltent même l'évêque
du diocèse de washington les présidents
vient d'utiliser une bible est l'une des
églises de mon diocèse sans autorisation
comme décor pour un message contraire
aux enseignements de jésus et à tous que
nos églises représente je ne peux pas
croire ce que mes yeux ont vu je suis
scandalisé pour ne rien arranger
donald trump s'est opposé frontalement
la cause des manifestants
le président américain a demandé aux
villes et aux états d'opter pour des
mesures fortes
dans le cas contraire il menace de faire
appel aux militaires
si une ville ou un état refuse de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
défendre la vie et les biens de ses
habitants alors je déplorais l'armée des
états unis et je résoudrai rapidement le
problème à leur place je prend également
des mesures rapides et décisives pour
protéger notre grande capitale
washington dc ce qui s'est passé dans la
ville hier soir est une honte absolue
toro che ce crysis pic en ce moment-même
j'envoie des milliers des milliers de
soldats lourdement armés de personnel
militaire et de forces de l'ordre pour
mettre fin aux émeutes aux pillages au
vandalisme aux agressions et à la
destruction gratuite
l' affaire avait déjà mal commencé pour
le président américain alors qu'il
n'avait encore fait aucune déclaration
officielle
donald trump a choqué en qualifiant les
manifestants de voyous et en demandant
une réponse exemplaire quitte à tirer
sur la foule
un message très mal perçues notamment
par twitter qui a décidé de masquer le
tweet en question et de signaler une
apologie de la violence
un comportement qui a même poussé une
partie des forces de l'ordre à lui
tourner le dos de nombreux policiers ont
tenu à soutenir le mouvement en posant
un genou au sol
d'autres ont voulu faire entendre leur
voix comme le chef de la police de
houston au micro de cnn
je veux m'adresser au président des
états unis en tant qu'officier de police
de ce pays
s'il vous plaît si vous n'avez rien de
constructif à dire fermez là quelques
manches à après le court aux navires us
donald trump doit gérer une nouvelle
crise qui prend la forme d'une fracture
à la fois racial et social
une situation qui pourrait lui coûter
cher à cinq mois de la présidentielle
américaine un candidat démocrate à la
présidentielle américaine joe biden a
réagi à la sortie médiatique
controversée de donald trump pour lui le
président américain est plus intéressé
par le pouvoir que par sa tâche de
subvenir aux besoins de ses citoyens
nous devons être vigilants face à la
violence que le président en exercice
fait subir à notre économie et à notre
justice
lorsque des manifestants pacifiques sont
dispersés avec des gaz lacrymogènes et
des grenades et claire pour qu'un
président puisse organiser une séance de
photos sur l'une des églises les plus
historiques du pays ou du moins à
washington dc on peut nous pardonner de
croire que le président est plus
intéressé par le pouvoir que par le
principe de subvenir aux besoins des
personnes dont il a la charge
car c'est ce qu'est la présidence le
devoir de se soucier de s'occuper de
nous tous pas seulement de ceux qui
votent pour nous mais de nous tous pas
seulement de nos donateurs mais de nous
tous le président a brandi la bible à
l'église saint john hier
j'aimerais qu'ils ouvrent de temps en
temps au lieu de la brandir pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec
françois durpaire spécialiste des états
unis bonsoir françois durpaire merci
d'être avec nous alors vous avez dit un
chez nos confrères de la dépêche
plus un acte de re révolution que des
émeutes
ça veut dire quoi en soi durpaire ça
veut dire que depuis le début de ce de
ces cycles de rébellion la presse
américaine est qualifiée toujours cela
de wired
c'est à dire des meutes pour les
disqualifier alors même que l'histoire
de ces rébellions noire dans l'histoire
des états unis
et bien c'est beaucoup de sit in et amis
d'inventivité très très forte c'est sont
aussi ce qu'on appelle des marches sont
aussi ce qu'on appelle des des fluides
hommes ride il ya énormément de
pacifisme mais souvent les médias au
cours de l'histoire ont occulté tout
cela montrer uniquement les images de
violence et on qualifier ça de riot
d'émeutes
alors même que la rébellion est au socle
de la démocratie américaine depuis la
boston tea party et vous avez vu
d'ailleurs que le président trunk il ya
quelques semaines a même appelé à la
rébellion mais il pensait que c'était
une bonne rébellion pour libérer de
minnesota pour libérer le michigan mais
c'était à l'époque contre les
gouverneurs démocrates alors l'onu a
condamné aujourd'hui une discrimination
raciale les discriminations raciales
dans le pays
hier c'était le basketteur michael
jordan qui est sorti de sa légendaire
réserve pour parler d'un racisme ont
créé aux états unis vont qui connaissait
par coeur ce pays
quelle est votre réaction alors est ce
qu'il ya un racisme plus important aux
états unis qu'ailleurs et notamment en
france je pense que vous avez entendu
les propos les propos du préfet de
police de paris il ya quelques minutes
sur votre antenne et vous aurez votre
réponse
l'amérique n'est pas plus raciste que la
france mais simplement il y a
aux etats unis la volonté de s'en sortir
complètement et je vais vous parler
brièvement du témoignage d'un homme très
important puisque c'est l'ancien maire
de minneapolis outhere aibaq et il dit
quoi aujourd'hui dans la presse il dit
j'ai failli à ma tâche
j'ai failli à ma tâche parce que
j'aurais dû réformer la police
qu'est ce que j'aurais dû faire
démilitariser la police mieux former les
policiers faire au sida police de
proximité mais dit il et c'est ça le
plus important
tout cela ne servira à rien si nous
américains blancs nous ne prenons pas
conscience d'une chose c'est la culture
de la peur c'est à dire qu'il ya du
danger pour les noirs à se déplacer dans
les rues américaines parce que les
blancs considère les noirs comme
dangereux vous voyez le siècle mortifère
je vous rappelle d'un mot simplement qu
aux etats unis
lorsque vous êtes un noir armés vous
êtes a battu par que lorsque vous êtes
un noir non armé
vous êtes abattu par la police comme
quand vous êtes un blanc armés vous êtes
arrêtés et menottés et dans tout ça
donne un tram qui semble souffler sur
les braises le président américain qui
se revendique aujourd'hui encore
président de la loi et de l'ordre
jusqu'où cette escalade peut aller de
notre âme dit je suis la loi et l'ordre
mais vous vous rappelez que c'est sa
campagne électorale de 2016 je suis le
candidat de l'ordre c'était sain
campagne c'est pas sous barack obama
qu'il y a eu de cette vague nationale en
revanche il ya effectivement eu des
graves problèmes sous barack obama
blacklight matin et n'est sous barack
obama mais pas ce mouvement national
alors ce qu'il faut bien souligner c'est
que aujourd'hui donald trump avec
certains de ses conseillers veut
l'emporter à la nixon en 1968 qui avait
dit je vais appeler la majorité
silencieuse ces américains qui restent
chez eux qui ne sont pas dans la rue
vont voter pour moi la seule différence
c'est que nixon n'étais pas président
qu'il était candidat de l'ordre mais
quand on est président en vient on est
comptable et ça veut dire que beaucoup
d'américains n'ont pas chez les
républicains qui voteront donald trump
non pas chez les démocrates qui de toute
façon votre ou joe biden
chez les indépendants et bien on se
posera la question est ce que ce n'est
pas un président du désordre vous savez
aujourd'hui l'amérique est polarisée
quand on est républicain on est plus
inquiet par les images de violences
urbaines que par l'image de cet homme
tué de manière raciste
lorsqu'on est démocrate celle inverse on
est plus préoccupé par le racisme que
peut-être ces émeutes dans la rue mais
lorsqu'on est indépendant c'est à dire
le ventre mou de la politique américaine
et c'est eux qui vont faire l'élection
on est préoccupé par les deux images à
la fois par la violence raciste des
policiers de certains policiers mais
aussi par la violence de certains
émeutiers et donc celui qui arrivera à
faire un discours d' équilibre pour
aller chercher ces gens qui sont
préoccupés par les deux est bien celui
là
un livre a gagné l'élection le 3
novembre prochain sauf qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une crise économique gravissime il ya
ces émeutes dont on parle
comment on va s'en sortir s'il n'y a
aucun leader qui cherche à apaiser la
situation de part et d'autre vous l'avez
vous l'avez dit le problème il est avant
tout économique c'est un problème
économique certains disent que c'est
l'année la pire de l'histoire moderne
des états unis vous à la fois un bilan
humain on parle de 2001 pour les pour le
world trade center mais là c'est un
bilan 30 fois supérieur cent mille morts
on parle de la grande dépression ou là
aussi cette année avec 40 millions de
chômage et 1968
les révoltes urbaines où les a aussi une
année donc extrêmement difficile
malcom x 10 et vous le savez le rêve
américain c'est pour certains mais nous
nous vivons le cauchemar américain et le
cauchemar américain à minneapolis il est
très très clair vous avez une différence
de 47 mille dollars entre un ménage
noire et un ménage blanc quand vous
pensez aux coronavirus dans l'état du
minnesota que je prends en exemple c'est
celui d'où tout est parti
6 % de personnes atteintes du
coronavirus mais si vous êtes un noir
américain 30 % et enfin si vous êtes né
ou à minneapolis
et bien si vous êtes né à minneapolis
vous avez 13 fois plus
de risques d'être tué par la police de
votre ville que si vous êtes un citoyen
blanc sans rapport avec la criminalité
les recherches ont montré qu'il n'y a
pas de lien entre la criminalité s'il
faut le dire et être noir d'ailleurs la
preuve il ya des quartiers noirs aisé
aux états unis ils sont pas touchées par
la criminalité
merci françois durpaire spécialiste des
états unis mais c'est d'avoir été avec
nous on dirait l'autre sur rt france et
retour en france coup d'envoi depuis ce
matin de la phase 2 du déconfinement fin
de la limitation des déplacements à 100
kilomètres de son domicile retour en
classe de davantage de collégiens et
lycéens les théâtres gymnases et
piscines des zones vertes peuvent à
nouveau accueillir du public réouverture
également des cafés et restaurants mais
uniquement des terrasses pour les
départements classés en zone orange
illustration à lyon où les restaurateurs
attendent avec impatience le retour des
clients grégoire douce et sur des images
de luis cabral
tout semble réuni pour la reprise dans
le quartier du vieux lyon
une météo clémente de belles tables un
personnel prêt à redémarrer
oui mais seulement les clients ne sont
pas vraiment rendez-vous dans
l'épicentre touristiques de la capitale
de la gastronomie française
les visiteurs étrangers se font rares
dans ses rues médiévales d'ordinaire
fréquenter une saison qui comme partout
en france s'annonce très délicate pour
les restaurateurs de la région franck
propriétaire d'un bouchon traditionnel
lyonnais peinent à faire respecter les
consignes sanitaires à l'intérieur
notamment la fameuse distance d'un mètre
entre les tables il aura pas trop de mon
goût
et puis après je pense que d'ici quinze
jours aux mêmes avant ça va ça va
stopper sa d'eramet est raide et
d'omettre sinon on ne peut pas
travailler c'est pas possible pas moi
encore ici j'ai une petite structure
mais je sais qu'il y beaucoup de
personnel dans les pauvres ils sont roux
dessus si ça met en avant mais lui le
prix du mètre carré des mesures
particulièrement difficile à appliquer
dans les bouchons lyonnais des
établissements souvent exigus dans
lesquels il est en temps normal et z
entendre la conversation de la table
voisine
franck croit au retour de jours
meilleurs mais selon lui seuls les plus
armées tiendront le coup s'est jamais
arrivé j'espère qu'on en a beaucoup qui
vont s'en sortir mais c'est pas évident
parce que la coupe est quand même
pendant trois mois je pas du tout de
recettes rien du tout 1500 euros après
impôts est un qu'il faut rendre le
rendent le pré c'est pas de l'argent
qu'on nous a donnée à bas cette année ça
va être chaud alors j'ai la chance
d'avoir les habitués français meurent
parce que mon est cotée sur quatre et
demi sur cinq c'est tout bête ces trucs
internet y connaît rien moi par la
playstation ou tu sais mais on a une
bonne cote
donc les habitués de lyon viennent mais
selon ceux qui font ça peut-être faire
du tri aussi parce que ce ne court pas
du tout la cote qui font n'importe quoi
qui les attrape touristes à eux ça va
être dur pour dans la rue du boeuf
passage obligé pour les touristes
l'incertitude est totale
sébastien propriétaire de plusieurs
bouchons ne sait pas encore s'il pourra
compter sur une clientèle étrangère dans
le vieux lyon il ya une
une particularité c'est qu'on travaille
beaucoup avec le flux touristique
on sait pas du tout quelle va être la
logique virtel qu'on va être ouverture
les consommateurs étaient encore peu
nombreux à l'heure du petit déjeuner ce
mardi en attendant une amélioration
espérer dans les prochains jours nos
équipes sont allés recueillir les
impressions des premiers clients
présents lors de la réouverture des bars
et des terrasses écouter ses réactions à
bordeaux et paris c'est important ça
fait deux mois que qu'on est on est chez
nous et on fait un peu ce qu'on peut
chez nous donc dès qu'on pouvait juste
sorti du manger plusieurs thibault là il
commence à faire beau tout le monde tout
le monde commence à vouloir sortir on a
eu l'autorisation de partir en vacances
donc on sait que les français sont au
rendez vous on compte sur eux pour être
au rendez-vous pour mai pour venir
manger pour venir relancer l'économie
française de la restauration d'un oui
c'était très très important et surtout
pour les clients qui viennent prennent
du plaisir parce qu'on vit en restant
prend du plaisir et je pense qu'au bout
de trois mois le c'est important je
pense que le 2 juin les gens qui
viennent on vraiment il souffle et prend
du plaisir c'est une certaine liberté
quoi pouvoir sortir pour
pouvoir voir les gens et
et sortir de chez nous surtout
éviter de se faire à manger à la maison
et voilà quand il ya des occasions
particulières de pouvoir m'a couvert
martégaux et de profiter on est ravis on
habite le quartier ça fait un moment
qu'on attendait l'ouverture des
terrasses pour troupes nos petites
habitudes
le petit café du matin en terrasse le
petit expresso c'est top
on est content de retrouver nos serveurs
nos théâtres nos petits yeux de vie
convivial vous voyez pas grand monde
la terrasse pour nous tout seul et ça
fait énormément de bien d'être être à
l'extérieur parce que moi j'habite en
appartement pas de terrasse pote balcon
donc là c'est vraiment
reprocher vraiment c'est une heure 22
avant de parler de cette réouverture des
bars et restaurants avec nos invités
un petit détour devant le tribunal où se
rassemblent en ce moment où un lieu un
rassemblement pour adama traoré les
esprits semblent s'échauffer
rassemblement interdit par la préfecture
de police à paris ce soir manifestations
organisées on le visait devant le
tribunal judiciaire par le comité de
soutien à la famille ni d'adama jeune
homme avant je vous le rappelle lors
d'une interpellation en juillet 2016 et
contre les violences policières
rassemblement qui n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune déclaration préalable selon la
préfecture de police dans un communiqué
on l'a appris un peu plus tôt dans la
soirée une contre-expertise médicale
indépendante réalisée à la demande des
proches du jeune homme valide les flics
ci par le placage ventrale et contredit
la dernière expertise judiciaire
discutant légendaire nous retrouverons
dans quelques minutes juste après le
face à face avec nos deux invités nous
retrouverons notre reporter à 21h30 en
direct depuis le tribunal judiciaire de
paris
et on en revient donc à ceux des
confinement phase ii avec la réouverture
des bars et restaurants aujourd'hui on
en parle avec alan
gm restaurateurs patron de plusieurs
établissements dans paris bonsoir à vous
merci d'être en direct ses consorts pour
la partie économie danil en nombre d
économistes atterrés merci aussi à vous
d'être en direct alors tout d'abord je
m'adresse aux aux restaurateurs allen gm
comment s'est passée cette journée à
haut risque entre guillemets écoutez moi
je suis chef de cuisine des trois
établissements à paris et aujourd'hui
j'avais un bistrot qui est au des 105
rue saint martin qui est j'ai la chance
d'avoir quelques tables que je réussis à
le mettre à l'extérieur presque 14
couverts à seize couverts
j'ai travaillé l'établissement qui ont
fait ce qui s'appelle le belge nicolas
flamel malheureusement il ya un trottoir
qui fait état d'un centimètre ben on n'a
pas du tout travaillé le qui durent
fermer l'établissement et la grosse
inquiétude pour mon établissement qui
étoit les quais dans le 16ème
arrondissement que toujours fermé il
n'ya pas terrasse pas de terrasse pas de
chocolat on ouvre le 23 juin et on sait
pas on est un peu dans l'incertitude
commencé à passer on va évidemment
revenir avec vous il n 1 gym sur les
contraintes vous avez dû subir notamment
aujourd'hui mesdames il ans j'aimerais
vous faire réagir justement adadja nous
disait qu'il y avait certains
restaurants notamment dans le xvième son
restaurant étoilé qui ne pouvaient pas
ouvrir on a entendu le cri un des chefs
étoilés en france ça fait partie du
patrimoine de notre pays dire que voilà
beaucoup de restaurants elle est tout
simplement mourir
or en france aujourd'hui alors c'est
effectivement quelque chose à craindre
tout dépendra effectivement des mesures
qui seront prises
on a eu un certain nombre de mesures qui
ont été prises à l'attention des
entreprises et en particulier les prêts
garantis par l'état
le problème c'est qu'un certain de pmi
ou de pme n'ont pas eu accès à ces prêts
garantis par l'état
et puis faut pas oublier non plus que ce
qui a été consenti ces des reports de
cotisations sociales encore les records
ça veut dire qu'à un moment ils vont ils
vont devoir les payer
donc à mon sens
c'est l'occasion ou jamais pour l'état
d'intervenir nous envoyer un signal
clair à l'attention des restaurateurs et
des commerçants en général surtout les
petits commerçants pour leur dire on va
vous soutenir et on va vous aider à
traverser ce moment difficile
on n'a aucun intérêt à ce que 20 à 25 %
des commerces aujourd'hui menacée mettre
la clé sous la porte d'autant plus que
ce sont souvent des commerces utile et
important à la vie de la nation aussi
bien au plan culturel qu'au plan
gastronomique comme moi ça me paraît
absolument essentiel même si ce
confinement devait être l'occasion de
réfléchir une transition vers autre
chose
et bien c'est effectivement on a affaire
ici au type de commerce qui doivent
survivre et dont on aura besoin aussi
dans le monde d'après quand on aura fait
la transition écologique est la neuvième
justement comment vous négocier ce
virage compliqué pour vous vous faites
partie de ces chefs qui tire vraiment la
sonnette d'alarmé vos restaurants sont
en danger pour certains écoutez moi
c'est vraiment je rentrais réaliser mon
rêve français jusqu'à 13 mars 2010 2020
tout s'est passé parfaitement bien
j'arrive en français à vingtaine
d'années j'ai construit dû commencer
derrien 2 0 et d'un seul coup les
restants ils sont fermés
j'ai jamais eu ça avant je pense c'est
la première fois aussi en france et
l'inquiétude beaucoup maintenant oui on
a eu de près dé l'état parce qu'on a
bien compris le message dans résumé de
tous les choses qui s'est dit ou tu te
rends de crédit ou tu vas faire là
failli tourner à choisy pointe des
crédits et en sachant on a déjà des
crédits on le rembourse chaque mois par
exemple moi j'ai une crédit sur sept ans
si on fait des enjeux remboursement
entre eux dit ça deviendrait cinq ans
maintenant j'ai ajouté ils crédit mais
j'ai pas trouvé une solution pour
l'acier pour la situation c'est juste je
rallonger que j'ai décalé les crédits
encore 12 mans pour le rembourser plus
l'épée jeu que j'ai repris ça veut dire
doubler crédit par là mais aujourd'hui
l'activité à ce que savard prennent
comme avant moi j'ai un récent qui
s'appelle nicolas flamel sa 100% du
schiste et il est basé sur les
américains canadiens australiens
quand est ce qu'on va voir ses touristes
et là à ce que les gens qui sont dans le
sud vont monter à paris si les cellules
et par exemple vont partir de paille
parce qu'on a subi les appartements à
paris ce tout petit avait rien on a
resté totalement enfermé
je pense en plus avec sous les provinces
et
le normandie en bretagne le style que
ouvert et durs envers ça veut dire tout
cas ouvert là bas je pense dans quelques
semaines la plupart exact il va rester
juillet ici on est inquiet oui on est
inquiet bien sûr je ne veux pas dire que
je vais laisser mes baisser les bras je
vais me battre mais là franchement ils
vont trouver l'énergie et la force
le mental à faire marcher
d'établissement des machines qui sont
arrêtés on arrêter complètement savez
aujourd'hui j'ai commencé mon premier
service dans mon bistrot l'équipe ça
fait des mois et demi sont sans activité
ça veut dire maintenant leurs muscles ça
affaiblit sont plus être père là ils
sont pas les douars à trier des deux
recettes doit adresser des choses c'est
vraiment entend recommencer dès 0 en
fait là les voisins ils sont venus ne
s'est tenue dans mon bistrot je veux
voir demain ou après demain parce que
les gens on va retourner encore au
restaurant est ce que ça sera une seule
fois pour dire bah merci
bon courage hambourg soutien mais après
c'est fini
franchement il répond l'économie des
nids langue aux inquiétudes légitimes de
la linge et amis qu'ils tombent en plus
se bat et garder la foi oui oui dont
mais ces inquiétudes sont plus que
légitimes on est en situation qu'on
appelle en économie une situation
d'incertitude radical on ne sait pas
exactement ce qui va se passer
effectivement pendant les mois de
confinement les ménages ont accumulé une
épargne et on aimerait bien qu'ils
aillent la dépenser dans votre
restaurant dans les autres restaurants
monsieur parce que ce sont des activités
utiles la ville du pays et puis c'est
qui qui assure en un grand nombre
d'emplois moi personnellement si j'étais
au manager je ferai en sorte qu'on
annule un certain nombre de dettes voire
de cotisations liées à cette situation
exceptionnelle à situation
exceptionnelle il faut des mesures
exceptionnelles
effectivement c'est très difficile de
prévoir ce que mon frère les gens
personnellement je pense qu'il faudra
annuler une partie de la dette pour
éviter justement qu on s'engouffre dans
une spirale où on va se retrouver avec
un certain de commerce comme celui de
monsieur qui risque de s'effondrer ce
serait la pire des situations possibles
moi je pense qu'il faut soutenir les pme
les schémas mis en alignant les dettes
en annulant une partie des cotisations
et surtout
ne faisons pas ce que certains
technocrates de bruxelles en tête c'est
à dire en ne baissant pas les salaires
parce que si on baisse les salaires
les premiers postes qu'ils prennent
c'est la culture et la restauration
parce que ça vraiment il ya des gens en
remercie et des gens à bruxelles qui
sautent qui on sentait ce serait la pire
des bêtises possibles ça nous emmènerait
dans une spirale de faillite et ça ne
ferait qu'aggraver la situation
alors j'ai amené quelques instants pour
terminer sur ces ce protocole sanitaire
assez lourd on le rappelle un mètre
entre les tables vous à paris voudrait
carrément effectivement pas le droit
d'ouvrir si vous n'avez pas de deux
terrasses comment vous gérez ça
justement est ce que les clients sont
tout de même au rendez vous ça fait peur
à tout le monde on va écouter
aujourd'hui j'ai parle de mon bistrot
j'ai eu des clients lui me dit j'ai des
clients le soir il y avait des spas
centres et des tables c'est potable
c'est vrai j'ai pas de jeu pas une
grande brasserie avec une grande
terrasse
moi je suis beaucoup basé sur la cuisine
de qualité les produits de saison
travail artistique ça veut dire les gens
il vient de moi dans ma salle g la
guerre là-bas qui je serais fine cuisine
déterrage effet pas des choses vraies
caen va aux terrasses ont envie mangé le
morceau de viande une salade à
l'intérieur moi j'y suis philippe
lusinchi très élaboré c'est une cuisine
des tables des services vraiment à la
française avec changement trou de
couverts et compagnes et beaucoup
d'allers-retours aller voir les clients
va écouter aujourd'hui quand je dis
c'est bien passé mais j'ai mal au ventre
huige aider l'établissement ils sont
très importantes
le prix des maisons de paris elle à
jamais dans elle existe depuis 1907 dans
toute l'histoire du que la flamme elle a
jamais fait en métaux lourds mois
maintenant aller permet même pas pendant
la guerre c'était vraiment le mail était
réfugié des dents maintenant elle est
fermée je ne sais pas comment le mettre
en route
c'est un refus qui est caché il n'y a
pas de touristes c'est vraiment là
certains peut-être j'ouvre maintenant en
septembre beaucoup tête pas et le reste
en éclats les s'associe à un autre débat
sur la gastronomie commence à l'être
dans l'avenir et yahia justice la chose
qui vraiment remercier on en fini s'il
vous plaît merci de ce que le temps
passe rapidement s'il vous plaît à dire
j'aime parce qu'on a eu beaucoup de
temps déjà
juste on a parlé beaucoup au mois
d'avril au niveau de supprimer les
loyers pour les entreprises qui semblent
des salaires et d'assurance et depuis on
parle plus maintenant nous avions
un qui sort des terrasses tout le monde
s'occupe à trouver des places pour les
tables on parle plus de ses charges
entre accumuler sur notre dos les
assurances de ces prisons il a dit je
serai attentif sur les assurances sans
rien faire sans qu'il a gagné à axât on
et 28000 contrat serait assurée chez axa
dont une personne qui a gagné et le
reste voilà merci à tous les deux en
tout cas on vous souhaite bon courage la
ga merci pour votre analyse l'économiste
dany langues
il est 21h30 de soyez venu si nous nous
rejoignons direct sur arte france on en
parle depuis le début de cette émission
un rassemblement en mémoire d'adama
traoré interdit par la préfecture de
police à paris ce soir une manifestation
organisée devant le tribunal judiciaire
par le comité de soutien à la famille
traoré adama traoré jeune homme mort
d'une interpellation en juillet 2016 et
contre les violences policières les
sauts rend les choses semblent se tendra
sur le terrain on va retrouver notre
reporter thomas bonnet en direct sur
place
thomas les esprits semblent s'échauffer
et l'ambiance commence à être beaucoup
plus électrique sur place
absolument et en fait ça coïncide d'une
façon assez hasardeuse avec la fin de
notre duplex précédent à la toute fin de
ce duplex des choses se sont échauffés
on ne pourrait pas vraiment vous dire
comment cela est arrivé
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
les forces de l'ordre qui étaient en
première ligne face aux manifestants ont
utilisé des gaz lacrymogènes en
direction d'une terrasse qui est situé
ou d'une d'estrade qui est située non
loin de là et ça a provoqué une colère
dans les rangs des manifestants s'en est
suivi des lancers de projectiles d'un
côté et un nombre assez important de
grenades lacrymogènes qui ont été tirés
qui continue d'ailleurs d'être tirées
par les forces de l'ordre on a
d'ailleurs nous dû s'éloigner un petit
peu puisque sinon l'air est irrespirable
beaucoup de personnes sont en train de
quitter la manifestation de notre côté
mais ce que vous pouvez peut-être
apercevoir sur ces images c'est que vous
avez donc à quelques mètres de nous des
fourgons de crs qui forment une rangée
quelque feux ont été allumés par des
manifestants semble-t-il est derrière
cette rangée de crs il y a encore un
important nombre de manifestants qui
sont toujours là qui continue donc à
échanger des tensions d un essai des
tensions qui règnent c'est la tension
qui règne ici alors que c'était vraiment
pas le cas il ya encore quelques
instants il se trouve que ce dérapage on
ne sait pas vraiment par quel biais il
est arrivé s'il ya quelqu'un qui a tenté
peut-être de forcer un barrage policier
ou si au contraire les policiers ont
provoqué d'une quelconque façon on n'est
absolument pas en mesure de vous dire
comment tout cela est parti
et le résultat c'est qu'effectivement
cette manifestation qui se voulait
pacifique et qu'il a été pendant un très
long moment et bien désormais elle elle
est le théâtre d'affrontements entre des
petits groupes de manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre
si thomas abonnés on vous retrouvera
certainement la fin de cette émission
est dans notre édition de 22h pour nous
tenir au courant de la situation fait
attention à vous en tout cas pour en
parler nous retrouvons michel fize
sociologue bonsoir michel fize merci
d'être avec nous vous avez certainement
vu michel fize ces images en direct
images de violence d'une manifestation
qui était calme au début qui dégénère
comme souvent quelle est votre première
réaction
vous savez le mouvement des gilet jaune
a révélé qu'il y avait eu un énorme
problème dans ce pays un problème d'
injustice un problème de discrimination
un problème de relation et plus
exactement de mauvaises relations entre
les citoyens et une partie une partie de
la police donc la crise sanitaire n'a
pas fait oublier à sa tombe de combat
qui était commencée avant et qu'ils
reprennent maintenant qu'on est sorti de
la phase la plus aiguë de 7 2 7 de cette
pandémie
- ces images me faisait penser plus
spécifiquement aux images américaine que
l'on voit actuellement bon pour un fait
d'ailleurs assez similaire bon mettant
en cause bon à tort ou à raison mais
apparemment à raison un à un policier
donc ça veut dire que c'est le monde qui
souffrent le monde je crois et il est
aujourd'hui dans une position de
tolérance zéro voyez ce type d'affaires
il y à 20 ou 30 ans aurait été enterré
et puis on serait passé à autre chose
voilà
eh bien je pense que aujourd'hui les
gens n'oublient pas voilà cette affaire
adama traoré n'est pas résolu et je
pense pour reprendre une expression très
gilet jaune que effectivement on ne
lâchera rien un du côté des défenseurs
de cette cause
mais je suis vous faisiez allusion au
gilet jaune est ce qu'on peut vraiment
finalement faire une comparaison entre
ce qui est en train de se passer devant
le tribunal judiciaire et les gilet
jaune
vous avez effectivement fait la
comparaison avec les états unis est ce
qu'on n'est pas justement dans ce
registre là d'une police qu'on accuse
parfois voilà selon certains de de
racisme
on parle également pour les détracteurs
de violences policières à ce que ce
n'est pas justement pas le même combat
avec gilet jaune est je pense qu'il ya
des il ya des ya des coïncidences entre
tous ces combats d'ailleurs on peut
penser que parmi ces personnes qui sont
dans la rue il y à des ex jdj les jaunes
qui viendront peut-être dans quelques
mois de futurs de futurs gilet jaune
je pense qu'on a une société qui est
éclatée qui est socialement fracturé de
tous les côtés plus rien ne va nulle
part donc tout explose un effectivement
en foyers d'un incendie ce soir demain
ce sera probablement un autre
un autre incendie parce que les
problèmes qui sont sur la table les
problèmes de discrimination les
problèmes
vous disiez de violences policières sont
des problèmes récurrents depuis depuis
une trentaine d'années la question
d'ailleurs des banlieues 1 le traitement
des banlieues n'a jamais été effectuée
marc malgré l'argent qu'on a pu qu'on a
pu distribuer bons la question des du
personnel soignant des moyens qui font
défaut n'est pas résolu la question des
avocats avec la paupérisation de cette
profession n'est pas résolu et j'allais
dire le problème des policiers eux-mêmes
qui se retrouvent d'ailleurs la double
situation d'être à la fois quelques fois
auteur et victime
globalement les policiers sont aussi des
personnes qui manquent de moyens qui
manquent d'effectifs qui manquent de
matériel voyez donc on espère la suite
on a souvent commenté ces après-midi les
jaunes ensemble sur ce plateau vous
étiez l'un de nos invités on disait
souvent justement que le combat des
régions ne s'était pas vraiment le
combat voilà des banlieues et cette
manifestation semble davantage justement
sur ce registre là on le rappelle le
comité adama traoré
on parle de déni de justice a third
adama traoré qui parle de déni de
justice et ce sont des problèmes qui se
superposent les uns sur les autres
alors superposition ou additions
effectivement les combats s'additionnent
les uns les autres à la recherche peut
être pour le moment d'une improbable
convergence un car ce combat qui
pourrait être un combat unique contre la
paupérisation contre la discrimination
contre l'éclatement sociales et bien
pour le moment ce sont des combats
catégoriels pour le pis souffrance est
telle catégorie d'à côté telle catégorie
de l'autre et puis bon pour ce qui
concerne les faits il est fait de ce
soir bon ça nous met effectivement face
à une société bon d'en penser qu'elle
n'intègre plus est d'abord elle
n'intègre plus par le travail et qu'elle
est encore sous le coup du racisme de la
xénophobie d'un certain nombre de
violences avait ça fait longtemps que je
parle des difficiles relations entre
entre les policiers et en particulier à
particulier les jeunes
bon bah c'est cette situation n'a pas
été résolue donc le problème en france
c'est que on ne prend un dossier à bras
le corps que quand le feu est là bas
peut-être avec l'étincelle de ce soir
qu'il y aura une une réflexion sur la
question de la fonction policière du
rôle de la police de la déontologie de
la police
et j'ajouterais de la formation de la
police à on a peut-être des policiers
manque de formation et puis bon entre
nous il y adeux tension à la fois chez
les auteurs et les victimes on est
d'ordre dans un monde qui ressemble un
volcan tout est en tension de tous les
côtés et donc il ya des pertes de sang
froid de part et d'autre dans des
relations qui finissent par ne plus être
des relations normales voilà où on
dialogue on essaie de trouver des
compromis
1 michel fize justement aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur est dans une
position il est voilà obligé défense et
police la police qui protège dans ce
pays les femmes et les hommes de tout y
compris du racisme
vous êtes étonné qu'on puisse en arriver
là une police qui est accusée clairement
de racisme aujourd'hui en france savez
je pense qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas évidemment généralisée bon j'ai dit
sur un autre plateau récemment que que
la police était raciste
alors je clarifie mon propos il y à des
policiers raciste ou plus exactement
peut-être des policiers qui n'aiment pas
telle ou telle catégorie de population
qui est peut-être effectivement le début
du racisme et enfin on a le droit de ne
pas aimer telle ou telle catégorie de
population sans tomber dans la
discrimination et et d'un aidant aidé en
aidant le racisme
bon il est évident que il ya des études
qui ont été qui ont été faites notamment
par des collègues du cnrs une dizaine
d'années qui m'ont très bien qu'il y
avait toujours des discriminations par
rapport aux contrôles d'identité par
exemple que si vous étiez maghrébins ou
de couleur noire vous aviez entre six et
huit fois plus de risques d'être d'être
interpellé que une personne bombe
appelons-la blanche comme on dirait
comme on dirait aux attentes aux états
unis bon ça ce sont ce sont des faits ce
sont des faits sur lesquels il faut
apporter des réponses
alors du côté évidemment des auteurs de
ces violences il faut savoir que
beaucoup sont aussi dans des situations
sociales très compliquée par rapport à
ce que
irrité par rapport au travail donc je
précise bien je n'excuse pas les faits
moi je n'ai pas excusé a condamné ou à
me féliciter voilà j'essaie une dernière
question on a vu ce panneau brandi par
les manifestants aux unions et
solidarité contre le fascisme d'état le
sociologue que vous êtes est étonné
est-ce que vous avez déjà pu lire ce
genre de pancartes en france toutes ces
dernières années alors le mot fascisme
je ne l'avais pas vu depuis un certain
temps qui avait été plutôt remplacé par
populisme
bon si on va préciser qu un populisme de
droite et un populisme de de gauche mais
ça montre bien qu'il ya aussi des
combats à côté ou à l'intérieur qui sont
aussi des combats politiques des combats
de radicalisation politique qui a un
autre projet de société qui est portée
comme c'était le cas pour les gilet
jaune comme c'était le cas pour les
membres de nuit debout il ya il ya
quatre ans bon appelons ça un projet
anarchiste au sens d'une égalité d'une
autre façon de de faire de fer politique
une autre façon de faire société
merci michel fize sociologue d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france pour
évoquer ces tensions qui se déroule en
ce moment devant le tribunal judiciaire
de paris où avait lieu un rassemblement
en soutien au comité d'adama crao traoré
le périphérique est désormais envahi on
va retrouver notre reporter thomas
abonnés qui en direct sur place thomas
je le disais effectivement beaucoup de
tension est palpable on peut le voir en
direct sur ces images est désormais le
périphérique parisien qui semble avoir
été
envahissent alors écoutez du point où
nous sommes nous avons accès au
boulevard des maréchaux qui est vraiment
juste à côté du parvis du tribunal
effectivement ce qu'on peut voir c'est
des épais panache de fumée à quelques
endroits et ainsi que les la fumée
blanche propre au gaz lacrymogène qui
continuent d'être utilisés par les
forces de l'ordre on a vu tout à l'heure
des pompiers qui étaient en route pour
intervenir justement on imagine sur ces
incendies
situation toujours très confuse puisque
un certain nombre de manifestants
revient par les artères où nous sommes
il quitte l'endroit où les tensions sont
les plus vives ils reviennent souvent
avec les yeux rougis nous explique que
ils ont respiré beaucoup de gaz
lacrymogène et qu'ils ont évidemment
quitter les lieux pour cela mais vous le
voyez peut-être sur ces images la fumée
était épaisse que ce soit de la fumée
des incendies qui ont été allumés par
certains manifestants ou par les fumées
provoquées par les gaz lacrymogènes
voyez qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup il est
difficile un épais brouillard qui est en
train de mener des brouillards qui est
en train de se créer derrière moi
beaucoup de tension les forces de
l'ordre sont toujours déployées en
nombre et ce qui est assez paradoxal
aussi c'est que la circulation a repris
ici là où nous sommes
il n'y avait pas de voiture jusque là
qui était présente ici est désormais il
ya des voitures qui circulent à nouveau
ce qui provoque évidemment un
embouteillage assez important pour
imaginer puisqu'il est impossible
d'accéder un peu plus loin ici
merci thomas bonne et on va les
retrouver
michel fize semble-t-il sociologue qui
est resté finalement avec nous avant de
retrouver un autre invité en direct sur
rt france
michel fize alors vous n'êtes pas de vin
bien évidemment mais c'est vrai que ces
images voilà peuvent étonner en pleine
crise sanitaire effectivement ces jeunes
on peut voir non masqué qui envahissent
le périphérique
selon vous c'est un mouvement qui
pourrait s'inscrire dans une forme de de
durée à l'instar des états unis où ça
fait une semaine que chaque nuit est
jalonnée de violences et d'émeutes
[Musique]
vous savez je pense que ce sont des ce
sont des foyers de colère qu'il
s'inscrive dans la durée bon comme vous
je partage l'idée que nous n'en savons
rien mais il est évident que ces faits
peuvent se reproduire
pas nécessairement s'inscrire dans un
dans un combat combat quotidien mais il
dénote que d'abord dans l'esprit de la
part de beaucoup de français le
déconfinement signifie un retour
quasiment à la vie normale
en tout cas c'est la manière dont ce
message de déconfinement a été
appréhendé et par conséquent tous les
problèmes qui étaient en suspens sont
réveillés voilà parce qu'encore une fois
les français qui ont souffert du
confinement n'ont rien oublié
ils n'ont pas oublié les rancoeurs
contre le politique et en particulier
contre l'exécutif qui probablement
risque d'être pris à partie très souvent
encore dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent pas c'est peut-être le temps
des vacances des vacances d'été donc on
est si vous permettez l'image c'est une
traînée de poudre
voilà et une traînée de poudre eh bien
on la stoppe on la stoppe pas mais ce
soir c'est à cet endroit demain ce sera
peut-être à un autre endroit
si encore une fois les problèmes ne sont
pas résolus
je pense qu'il ya une grande
détermination des citoyens aujourd'hui à
ne plus
rien laisser passer ils veulent que les
problèmes soient résolus
voilà assez de rapport à cette
commission denquête ou pas parlementaire
ou pas il faut de l'action il faut
résoudre résoudre ses difficultés
bon sauf qu'on a attendu trente ans et
que maintenant tous les problèmes ne
saute à la figure
michel fize en l'occurrence là il ya une
colère assez précise enfin on
connaissait évidemment ce comité d'adama
traoré avec plusieurs expertises
judiciaires qui écarté la responsabilité
des gendarmes de au total et puis ce
soir effectivement peut-être la raison
en partie de la colère une nouvelle
contre expertise médicale indépendante
réalisée à la demande des proches du
jeune homme
il valide l'asphyxient par plaquage
ventrale et qui contredit ainsi la
dernière expertise judiciaire qui
discutent les gendarmes
on peut regretter tout de même voilà et
se poser des questions sur ce type d'
expertise une fois c'est oui une fois
c'est non on discute et gendarmes une
autre fois non quelle est votre réaction
par rapport à ça savez je je je dirais
qu'il suffit que il ne soit pas disculpé
une seule fois pour que soient mis le
feu aux poudres
1 parce que ça veut dire que ya
évidemment une incertitude
1 par conséquent une présomption de
culpabilité de la police est ce que vous
dites
effectivement et que j'avais lu semble
confirmer quand même qu'il y à bien
semble-t-il une responsabilité des
forces de l'ordre dans cette affaire ce
qui nous renvoie d'ailleurs aux états
unis de la même manière ou la
culpabilité et plus avérée aux états
unis mais ça montre vient encore une
fois que les grandes discrimination aux
états unis entre les blancs et les noirs
ici entre effectivement les français à
la peau blanche et et les autres venus
de l'immigration même si pour certains
font peur bleue que tout tout c'est tous
ces conflits sont pendants ne sont pas
résolus voilà et les gens je pense by
réaffirme que ils veulent être traités
comme les autres peut être interpellé de
la même manière quel que soit la couleur
de la peau quelles que soient ses
origines ses appartenances ses
appartenances politiques
voilà je pense qu'on est face à un an né
fasse vraiment un craquement général un
craquement général voilà et donc ça
laisse ouverte la porte à toutes sortes
évidemment d'hypothèses un don dont un
épisode révolutionnaire j'allais presque
dire en bonne et due forme
merci michel 6 d'avoir été avec nous à
la proue voit toujours sur ces images
les incidents à paris donc en marge de
la manifestation contre les violences
policières organisée par le comité de
soutien d'adama traoré on va aller en
parler avec madjid messaoudene
conseiller municipal de seine saint
denis qui a participé au rassemblement
tout à l'heure bonsoir monsieur
messaoudène merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france vous avez d'autres
races participé à ce rassemblement il
semble que vous soyez revenu chez vous à
l'heure qu'il est racontez nous parce
qu'au début c'était une manifestation
très calme qui semble avoir dégénéré à
l'heure qu'il est alors effectivement le
rassemblement a duré très longtemps il y
avait beaucoup de prises de paroles moi
ce que j'ai noté
j'ai pas forcément envie de commenter
les heures parce que je sais que c'est
ce que vous voulez à retenir certaines
personnes à commencer par le préfet
didier lallement qui a voulu interdire
ce rassemblement dont qui a jeté de
l'huile sur le feu puis je rappelle que
didier lallement
les personnes qui ont envahi le
périphérique donc effectivement vous
savez aussi bien que moi vous connaissez
les médias l'endettement on va forcément
et nécessairement retenir ces images de
violence voilà avec un pays
il en existe c'est pour ça madame c'est
pour ça madame que moi je reviens sur ce
qui s'est passé avant le périphérique
n'a pas été envahie par assa traoré sa
famille il a été envahi par des gens
s'est passé pas des choses que j'ai
forcément envie de commenter ce que je
dis c'est qu'il reste vivant dans son
délai pardonnez moi juste cette question
ce que vous condamnez justement ce genre
d'attitude ou les justifier non mais moi
je dis juste qu'il ya une colère
légitime dans ce pays
face aux violences policières et il faut
l'entendre il ya un texte qui est sorti
ya pas très longtemps justement
là-dessus on pourra dire que la colère
des quartiers populaires étaient
légitimes il ya des familles aujourd'hui
dans ce pays et madame qui ne peuvent
toujours pas faire le deuil de leurs
enfants tués par les forces de l'ordre
parce que la justice n'ait toujours pas
rendu donc je je je refuserai toujours
de comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable
tout à l'heure avant que vous me
montriez ces images il y avait un
rassemblement avec des centaines de
personnes venues de partout des jeunes
des moins jeunes des personnes blanches
des personnes non blanches qui sont
venus réclamer vérité et justice pour
adama traoré mais également pour sabri
décédé à argenteuil récemment et dans
une affaire dans laquelle la police
était encore là un pic est ce qu'on est
venu dénoncer tout à l'heure madame
c'est l'impunité de la police qui est la
règle
combien de policiers sont allés en
prison après avoir tué des gens aucun
c'est dire que tant que la police ne
sera pas qpi tant que l'impunité sera la
règle tant que les hiérarchies
administratives et politiques et le
parquet que décideront que les policiers
ne sont jamais responsables de la mort
qui de cause alors la colère continuera
de nous rôder dans ce pays il faut juste
l'entendre les gens qui sont devenus
tout à l'heure ne sont pas venus pour
être violent ils sont dus pour dénoncer
la violence d'un corps constitués qui
s'appelle la police nationale et qui
s'appelle également la gendarmerie cette
gendarmerie qui a tué adama traoré en
2016 le jour de ses 24 ans donc c'est ça
qu'on est annoncé tout à l'heure
ces violences policières on n'en peut
plus on n'en peut plus de compter noma
on n'en peut plus de voir des familles
endeuillées
on n'en peut plus de voir des mères qui
pleurent leurs enfants et qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire le deuil parce que les
policiers ne sont toujours pas inquiétés
c'est ça qu'on est venu dire aujourd'hui
a défendu la police dans tout comme le
préfet vous l'avez cité didier
elle ment lollichon selon le ministre de
l'intérieur qui protège dans ce pays les
femmes et des hommes de tous y compris
du racisme effectivement il y à
certaines voix qui dénoncent une forme
de racisme dans la police est ce que
vous en faites partie clairement mais
clairement il y à du racisme dans la
police d'ailleurs pourquoi il n'y aurait
pas de racisme dans la police
quand il y en a dans la société enfin je
veux dire c'est tout à fait incohérent
de 2,2 de dire qu'il n'y aurait pas de
racisme devant la police le problème en
plus qui se rajoute quand il ya du
racisme dans la police c'est que les
policiers sont armés et quand ces
policiers sont armés notamment dans des
quartiers populaires bas ça se
transforme
hélas souvent en violences policières
mortels ou non et tous les jours des
jeunes dans les quartiers populaires se
font taper par les policiers c'est
quelque chose qui est notoire le fait de
vouloir être dans le déni comme l'est le
préfet d'allemand c'est juste
inacceptables on voit bien que c'est pas
lui qui vit tous les jours des contrôles
le facétieux du jour appelle madame
qu'en 2016 la cour de cassation a
condamné l'état français pour contrôles
au faciès
donc comment peut-on dire aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y a pas de racisme dans la
police il faut réformer la jouer la
question en tout cas moi je me pose des
questions
non mais ce soir c'est une question
rhétorique madame me dire que je sais
très bien vous faites votre travail et
que vous posez la question donnez
l'occasion de répondre
absolument ce que je vous dis madame
c'est qu'il ya du racisme dans la police
que ce racisme il est il des fois il tue
et on l'a vu dans les quartiers
populaires c'est trop mais depuis de
trop nombreuses années bastamag a fait
un dossier dans lequel il recense entre
2007 et 2017
une soixantaine de jeunes de deux morts
deux personnes qui ont croisé de forces
de l'ordre avec trois condamnations et
euros policiers en prison voilà le
résultat de l'igpn qui ne sert qu'à
blanchir les violences policières et les
meurtres commis par par la police il
faut il faut qu'on arrête avec nous en
madjid messaoudene tout à l'heure vous
soulignez à juste titre effectivement
que la manifestation avait été calme
pendant plusieurs heures il n'empêche on
rappelle que cette manifestation était
interdite par la préfecture de police de
paris pour deux raisons parce que voilà
n'était pas apparemment déclaré selon la
préfecture et deuxièmement parce que on
est en crise sanitaire et qu'aujourd'hui
tout simplement les rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes sur la voie
publique sont
interdit pour tout le monde pour tout à
chacun est ce que vous êtes étonnés
justement que les choses dégénèrent de
la sorte alors que à la base c'était une
manifestation tout simplement interdite
moi ce qui me choque davantage c'est je
sais pas si j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est que monsieur l'allemand se servent
de cette crise sanitaire de cet état
d'urgence sanitaire pour interdire les
mobilisations citoyennes comme celles
adama traoré
si le rassemblement appelé par le comité
à damas n'était pas sur les vieux ne
m'avait pas été sur les violences
policières du diamant ne leur est pas
interdit
il est insupportable pour les forces de
l'anp à 300 personnes sur le blick
personne n'y échappe maintenant
lentement mamba a coûté en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il ya eu un
rassemblement a bondi hier pour gabriel
qui a pu se tenir ils étaient plus de 10
sauf que gabriel
son cas n'est pas celui d' adama traoré
et d'april et par pension politique que
compris à capri le comité adam a donc on
va bien qu'en fait il ya deux poids deux
poids deux mesures je me félicite il est
plus tenir à bondy le rassemblement ce
que je note c'est que des policiers sont
allés au domicile face à traoré
aujourd'hui pour l'intimider et empêcher
que le rassemblement ne se tienne ou
alors on en est aujourd'hui
dans ce pays il faut qu on puisse
manifester contre les violences
policières dans ce pays est contre et
contre tout ce qu'on trouve d'injuste et
d'heures et de révoltant et ce n'est pas
ce qu'on se salit terre qu'ils ont pu
nous en aurons sera et c'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire ah ça traoré en maintenant le
le le
comment dire le rassemblement
aujourd'hui meilleurs qui ont émaillé
ces rassemblements ne peuvent pas être
ne peuvent pas résumer ce qui s'est
passé tout à l'heure mais encore une
fois si on parle de vies humaines
on parle de vies humaines pas de dégâts
matériels ce sont des vies qui sont
volés par les forces de l'anp chaque
année dans ce pays
merci beaucoup m'a dit d'un messaoudène
d'avoir intégré qui vous conseiller
municipal de seine saint denis et il est
presque 22
en direct sur arte france nous vous
rejoignons si vous nous rejoignez pardon
les images en direct de ces incidents à
paris en marge de la manifestation
contre les violences policières
organisée par le comité de soutien
d'adama traoré comité de soutien
donc de ce jeune homme noir mort d'une
impériale interpellation en juillet 2016
contre les violences policières
organisation qui n'a fait ans précise
l'objet d'aucune déclaration préalable
selon la préfecture de police dans un
communiqué on l'a appris
peu avant 20h une contre-expertise
médicale indépendante réalisée à la
demande des proches du jeune homme
valide l'asphyxient par le placage
rentrer à les contredire ainsi la
dernière expertise judiciaire disculpant
les gendarmes et on va retrouver en
direct sur place devant le tribunal
judiciaire de paris où se tenait le
rassemblement initialement un
rassemblement thomas bonnet qui a été
plutôt calme
notre invité précédent nous le disent et
cannes pendant plusieurs heures et puis
soudainement la situation qui semble
avoir dégénéré avec des jeunes qui ont
notamment envahi le périphérique
parisien
[Musique]
oui rassemblement qui s'était très très
calme très pacifique pendant deux bonnes
heures au mans puisque à partir de 18
heures il y avait déjà beaucoup de monde
sur le parvis du tribunal de paris
et c'est véritablement aux alentours de
20h30 21h que les choses se sont un peu
échauffés avec comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure des tensions entre des
crs qui étaient présents devant ces
risques étaient présents devant le
cordon devant lui le cortège pardon de
la manifestation les esprits se sont un
peu échauffés et depuis c'est les gaz
lacrymogènes voiliers qui ponctuent
encore là on voit des fumées de gaz
lacrymogène il ya des petits groupes de
manifestants que vous allez peut-être
pouvoir apercevoir ici qui sont en train
de revenir du parvis puisque la police
c'est désormais pour y déployer à
beaucoup d'endroits différents
il n'y a pas vraiment un groupe de
manifestants et un groupe de forces de
l'ordre il ya des petits groupes un peu
sporadiques qui est bien tente parfois
de quitter l'endroit où il ya un peu
trop de lacrymogènes pour les forces de
l'ordre essaient de regagner du terrain
il ya aussi les pompiers qu'on voit en
plus au loin là bas qui ont éteint il ya
quelques instants un petit feu de
poubelle qui était juste derrière moi
merci thomas bonne et on va retrouver
michel fize qui nous accompagne pour
effectivement commenter ces incidents
ces images en direct michel fils vous
l'avez expliqué effectivement ce qui
semble être l'analyse pour vous de cette
situation il n'empêche nous sommes
toujours en pleine crise sanitaire
situation voilà d'urgence jusqu'au 10
juillet pour le pays avec on le disait
aussi une manifestation interdite
également raison de cette crise
sanitaire où on le rappelle quand même
les rassemblements au delà de 10
personnes sont interdits sur la voie
publique est ce qu'il n'était pas
finalement prévisible que cette
manifestation dégénère ce soir
je pense que ce dont nous souffrons
quand on voit ces images c'est de la
disparition de tous les relais de
médiation de dialogue qui permettait de
mettre autour d'une table les
protagonistes manifestement il ya un
refus d'agir de cette manière on a un
peu le sentiment que la réponse en
l'occurrence du politique c'est le
discours donc un discours correspond un
autre discours au discours premier un
contre discours et de discours en
discours est bien on voit les images les
images se perpétuer donc je pense que il
faut réinventer ou plutôt inventer parce
qu'il n'a jamais existé il faut inventer
un véritable dialogue social 1 qui met
en face à face les institutions
traditionnelles je pense en particulier
aux syndicats aux partis politiques mais
également tout ce corps de citoyens en
action à la gent repense encore une fois
aux anges il est jaune et leurs
aspirations une démocratie plus directe
moi je pense que nous sommes face et ça
me rappelle un peu les états unis nous
sommes face aux pièges de la
toute-puissance présidentielle alors qui
est avéré en france
la toute-puissance présidentielle qui
écrase tous les relais tous les organes
où on pourrait attendre
effectivement à une ouverture d'une
négociation dans cette affaire adama
traoré
bien sûr qu'il faut que la justice passe
or la justice manque de moyens donc elle
parce que moins en moins vite
d'une part 2 les policiers effectivement
sont des citoyens comme les autres mais
ils sont tout de même si toi aussi tu as
faim traités comme des citoyens
pas tout à fait comme les autres donc
alors qu'il devrait être sanctionné
comme les autres citoyens en réalité eh
bien ils sont sanctionnés souvent moins
durement alors que entre nous il devrait
l'être davantage puisque il assume une
fonction d'autorité 1 et dans un devoir
d'exemplarité
donc avec du sang froid de la maîtrise
de la formation à la gestion de deux
gros pour ne pas tomber
évidemment dans dans les provocations
aussi qu'on peut leur adresser quelques
fois voilà donc ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est que on éteint dans une
société complètement désagréger qui part
en lambeaux de tous les côtés michel
fize cette situation en pleine crise
sanitaire vous êtes tous même étonné que
ça puisse arriver où finalement c'est
assez logique les gens sortent de
effectivement deux mois et demi de de
confinement c'était une situation tendue
notamment dans les banlieues est ce que
c'était tout simplement prévisible ce
qui se passe alors d'abord j'ai constaté
autour de moi sans pouvoir généraliser
que cette sortie du confinement
avec le retour de la liberté relative
s'est fait quand même avec beaucoup
d'agressivité
alors il évoque la température peut
aussi contribuer à réchauffer un peu les
esprits mais je trouve que d'une manière
générale les français
les parisiens en particulier que je
connais le mieux
voilà sont quand même très tendue on a
un peu l'impression qu'on revient encore
une fois aux disputes entre
automobilistes entre piétons pas là tant
que c'est encore une fois des des
citoyens à fleur de peau alors
évidemment là on chercherait en vain les
gestes barrière la distanciation sociale
voilà donc là on est en train d'assister
à une crise
qui est en train de se mêler à une crise
encore en cours qui la crise sanitaire
tant qu'on attend même pas que la crise
sanitaire soit complètement que évacuer
ce qui pour bien encore une fois ce
sentiment d'injustice et de colère qui
encore une fois bien de très très loin
voilà et qui en est à ce niveau là parce
qu'il n'a pas été traité depuis toutes
ces années
merci michel fize en direct donc sur rt
france on va retrouver quelques minutes
madjid messaoudene conseiller municipal
de 200 smic est toujours avec nous on a
interviewé déjà longuement tout à
l'heure madjid messaoudene qu'on vous
voyez ces images tout de même qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire vous êtes voilà
triste en colère compréhensif ça vous
inspire quoi c'est ces images de
violence alors qu' il faut être honnête
les français sortent d'une période très
difficile on a tous été confiné chez
nous une situation compliquée pour tous
les concitoyens
et effectivement on sort de là des
images de violence dans les
manifestations ça vous inspire quoi
écoutez moi je prends encore une fois je
je je suis pas en train de dire que je
suis ravi de voir des pompiers effective
et sur la voie publique mais encore une
fois je ne peux pas oublier mois la
violence qu'on a vécu pendant
confinement je rappelle que les
violences policières n'ont pas été
confinés il ya eu au moins sept plaintes
pendant confinement notamment dans les
quartiers populaires où des jeunes se
sont fait frapper par par là par la
police et des plaintes déposées auprès
de l'igpn avec le succès qu'on connaîtra
hélas
et puis je me rappelle - de la façon
dont les forces de l'ordre se sont
comportés lors des mouvements sociaux
sncf ratp et les hôpitaux je me rappelle
qu'avant d'un peu dire les soignants il
frappait les soignants donc il faut
relativiser
un certain nombre de choses là on parle
de dégâts matériels
je suis pas en train de dire que c'est
formidable nous sommes en train de dire
qu'il ya une colère et que l'école elle
s'exprime et qu'il faut entendre que le
slogan indices torrent qui a été scandé
aujourd'hui c'est que il sans justice il
n'y aura pas de paix et tant qu'il n'y
aura pas de juste
il est temps que les policiers ne seront
pas punis pour ce qu'ils font
tant que les femmes ne reconnaîtra pas
qu'il y ait effectivement avant racisme
systémique et dans les institutions
il n'y aura pas les gens continueront de
sortir pour dénoncer les agissements de
la police et des forces de l'ordre
alors effectivement il ya des pneus qui
brûlent il ya des poubelles qui brûlent
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
chaque année c'est des vies qui sont qui
sont brisées
c'est des familles qui sont endeuillées
et que pour moi c'est incomparable on
peut pas mettre sur le même pied ces
choses là alors je peux comprendre que
certaines personnes dans leur confort
voulais voir autre chose pendant pour
leur première sortie de déconfinement
sauf que dans les quartiers populaires
la situation a été compliquée en seine
saint denis par exemple on a été juriste
au 0 des russes surexposés à la misère
et est surexposé violences policières
bon une fois que notamment les gens qui
nous écoutent auront compris ça je pense
qu'ils pourront mettre sur un autre plan
les images qui peuvent à diffusée en ce
moment sur votre antenne merci madjid
messaoudene d'avoir été avec nous et on
continue donc de commenter ces images
effectivement de tension actuellement à
paris je vous le disais en marge de la
manifestation contre les violences
policières en soutien
adama traoré ce jeune homme qui avait
été tué lors de son interpellation
juillet 2016 on va refaire une autre
réaction celle d'abel boeing président
de l'association forces républicaines
bonsoir avait aboli merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france je me pose
la même question qu à l invité précédent
quand vous voyez ces images une
rassemblement calme sur plusieurs heures
qui dégénère aujourd'hui dans les rues
de paris qui se dé confine à peine
quelle est votre réaction
alors remonté ses soeurs je veux dire
que personne ne va se réjouir lorsqu'il
ya des images de violence lorsqu'il ya
des images de feu des images de casse
mais il est important de pouvoir se
concentrer rapidement sur la source du
problème à savoir que vous avez toute
une partie de la population tout ou
partie de notre jeunesse qui vivent avec
ce sentiment d'injustice au quotidien et
malheureusement il se trouve que pour
eux cette phase de confinement a été une
phase qui a exacerbé les injustices que
ce soit vous avez de la police mais
vis-à-vis de l'état et que des de tout
ce qui représente l'institution étatique
et on se retrouve avec les mêmes
problèmes qu'il ya 30 ans je ne serai
pas très original en disant cela mais
c'est toujours important de le rappeler
le problème du cloisonnement
géographique la performance de l'école
qui diffèrent de façon très injuste d'un
territoire à l'autre et ça se répercute
sur l'avenir de ces jeunes qui
lorsqu'ils deviennent adultes n'arrive
pas à se projeter dans une identité
française qui leur permettent de
s'émanciper pleinement dans notre
merveilleux pays
donc effectivement nous ne sommes pas
pour de la casse ne s'empare pour la
violence mais il est important de
pouvoir creuser les choses et c'est là
que le politique a fait défaut et que
malheureusement il continue à faire des
fours aujourd'hui selon vous qu'est ce
qui a mis le feu aux poudres dans cette
manifestation qui se voulait à la base
pacifique elle rompt le rappelle c'est
peut-être un début de réponse vous allez
me dire voilà si vous êtes d'accord avec
ce diagnostic mais effectivement une
expertise judiciaire qui a écarté les
responsabilités des gendarmes par deux
fois dans le passé et une nouvelle
contre expertise ce soir médicale
indépendante réalisée cette fois la
demande des proches du jeune homme qui
valide l'asphyxié donc qui donne la
responsabilité aux gendarmes
ces deux là selon vous que vient la
colère est tout à fait et puis il faut
imaginer vraiment la situation qui est
libre dans laquelle se retrouve
aujourd'hui la famille d'adama traoré à
chaque fois qu'il y à des expertises on
va dire entre guillemets officiel ça va
dans le sens du fait que adama traoré ne
serait pas mort étouffé par des
policiers et à chaque fois qu'il ya des
expertises indépendantes ça va dans
l'autre sens donc vous avez une famille
qui en a marre d'être assis à 6 entre
deux chaises et vous avez toute une
population parce que cette famille elle
incarne quelque part le rapport
difficile delà d'une partie de la
jeunesse française et avec l'identité
française et avec tout ce qui représente
l'autorité française donc bien entendu
c'est une situation qui est vraiment
délicate et on voit effectivement qu'il
ya beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ne sont pas
normales dans un pays comme la france ne
te rappeler aussi que lorsque cette
affaire a éclaté malheureusement vous
avez quand même un procureur de la
république est venu mentir devant les
caméras en disant que le jeune adama
traoré avait des foyers infectieux dans
le corps ce qui était faux ce qui a été
démenti par la famille parce que cet
état d'un jeune qui était a priori en
pleine santé et qui comme georges fleuve
avait signifié aux policiers qu'il
n'arrivait pas à respirer
donc au bout d'un moment on ne peut pas
étouffer les problèmes dans une cocotte
minute et s'étonner lorsque ça explose
et je répète lorsque l'on dit cela ça ne
veut pas dire que l'on cautionne la
violence ça ne veut pas dire que l'on
cautionne ce qu'il se passe mais c'est
vraiment très difficile et il est
important pour les politiques d'aller au
fond du problème de traiter le problème
à la racine
on a vu avec cette pandémie du
coronavirus qu'on a eu à traiter des
foyers d'infection mais il faut
maintenant traiter les foyers
d'injustice qui risque d'exploser et
ak place de clichy si les choses
continuent de rester en l'état selon
vous justement traiter le problème à la
racine est ce que certains gouvernements
ont eu des politiques plus adapté selon
vous on imagine que vous serez d'accord
de dire que le problème ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
le problème ne date pas d'aujourd'hui je
ne serai pas très original et je ne vais
pas me lancer dans un cours d'histoire
et de sociologie mais le cloisonnement
géographique entraîne les situations qui
nous saute tous au visage
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que la mixité
sociale a été délibérément refusé par
bon nombre de pollutions 2-2 pardon de
décisions politiques depuis des
décennies et en plus ça a créé une
fracture dans la société
entre les populations des quartiers
populaires qui ont l'impression de ne
pas être acceptées mais aussi la
population va dire du milieu rural qui
ne comprend pas forcément tout ce qu'il
se passe et le politique n'a pas cherché
à unir la société française dans une
entité une et indivisible
on est sur un territoire où vous avez
malheureusement plusieurs france qui se
regardent avec méfiance aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que quand vous êtes noir
quand vous êtes arabe
quand vous êtes asiatique à avoir ce
sentiment permanent de devoir prouver sa
francité que lorsque vous dites que vous
êtes français
on va toujours vous demandez oui
français mais doux comme s'il y avait
des vrais français qui sont blancs et
défauts français qui ne sont pas de
phénotype blanc
c'est un problème qui dure depuis
longtemps et qui n'a pas été abordée et
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est une
alerte pour l'ensemble de la classe
politique
je pense qu'il est encore temps de
régler la situation mais si nous
laissons encore les choses passé en 10
ans en résumant la situation en disant
que c'est une bande de racailles qui est
venu casser non il faut aller à la
racine du problème
vous savez on parle souvent du thème de
la mère patrie eh bien vous avez des
enfants aujourd'hui de la mère patrie
qui ne se sentent pas aimé par cette
maman qui est censé les protéger et leur
permettent une émancipe une émancipation
citoyenne juste et équitable
c'est tout ce que ces jeunes demain
lorsque vous avez un enfant qui se sent
mal c'est du devoir du parent d'aller
vers lui pour savoir ce qu'il se passe
et ça n'a pas été fait le travail n'a
pas été poussé assez loin des choses ont
été faites je ne vais pas dire que rien
n'a été fait on n'est pas allé au bout
de la chose il faut décloisonner la
société française casser les castes
quand vous entendez christophe castaner
le ministre de l'intérieur justement se
défendent que la police
soit raciste vous vous dites quoi que on
a un problème dans ce pays que le
ministre l'intérieur soit obligé de
justifier justement les troupes de
policiers alors moi je vais être très
clair la police n'est pas raciste
les policiers sont les héros de la
nation vous voyez
par contre il y à du racisme au sein qui
est manifestée par certains éléments au
sein de la police et ce qui a tendance à
énerver mais pas que les jeunes on l'a
vu aussi avec la manifestation des gilet
jaune vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est à dire que lorsqu'il ya une bavure
policière qui est fait
il ya une sorte de corporatisme malsain
qui fait qu' on a l'impression que les
autres policiers ne veulent jamais
avouer que oui il se passe des choses
chez nous alors ça commence à faire
parce qu'il ya des représentants de
certains syndicats qui monte au créneau
et qu'ils reconnaissent effectivement
ces derniers jours qu'il peut y avoir
des bavures mais ça n'a pas été assez
fait on a l'impression d'un corporatisme
qui se couvre et lorsque la police des
polices est saisie pour une enquête sur
une bavure on voit que ça met du temps
et pour avoir accès aux résultats de ces
enquêtes
eh bien ce n'est pas aussi comment dire
ce n'est pas rendue aussi public que
lorsque la bavure elle-même éclate donc
tout ça ça concorde ça ajoute de l'eau
au moulin à tous ceux qui ont ce
sentiment d'injustice
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez de la part du gouvernement
vous dis qu'il faut traiter les
problèmes à la racine quelles seraient
les mesures j'imagine que vous y avez
réfléchi depuis longtemps quelles
seraient les mesures d'urgence justement
pour apaiser la situation
la problématique comme jeudi à trois
piliers importants donc le gouvernement
a commencé à y travailler je ne vais pas
être de mauvaise foi en disant que rien
n'est fait mais ce n'est pas suffisant
le cloisonnement géographique la
performance de l'école et la
problématique lorsqu'on arrive sur le
milieu du travail qui effectivement
lorsqu'un français et noir lorsqu'un
français et arabe lorsqu'un français et
asiatiques ou lorsqu'un français même
peut être blanc n'est pas de la bonne
pas du bon milieu social et bah c'est un
petit peu plus difficile il faut quand
même faire des vrais états généraux de
la situation mais pas une idée géniale
états généraux pour parler il faut
prendre des décisions et surtout cassé
le cloisonnement géographique et il faut
parler aussi à toutes les france toutes
ces france qui se regardent avec
méfiance tout c'est france qui peut qui
peuvent être confuse parce que il y a un
jeu médiatique je ne parle pas des
références bien entendu mais il est un
jeu médiatique de la part de vos
confrères qui ne favorise pas l'unité
nationale il faut que nous puissions
tous parler parce que l'on soit en
réalité noir blanc arabe d'origine
asiatique
lorsque l'on est dans la galère excusez
moi l'expression lorsqu'on est en bas de
l'ascenseur social
et lorsque l'on constate au quotidien
que cet ascenseur social n'a pas la
fluidité qu'il doit avoir c'est aussi
difficile il faut que les gens puissent
se parler
qu'est ce que les politiques doivent
faire il faut vraiment traiter la racine
et que la france aussi fasse la paix
avec son histoire à ce que je sais que
dès que l'on parle de ces sujets-là de
comment l'homme noir a pu être traitée
dans un passé encore récent souvent sa
crise tout le monde mais faut pouvoir en
parler pas pour accuser pas pour
s'accuser les uns les autres mais pour
être apaisées même la manière dont
l'histoire est enseignée à l'école vous
avez des chapitres entiers qui sont
camouflés et malheureusement vous avez
des jeunes qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
vont sur internet
alors quand ils tombent sur des
personnes qui quittent qui donne des
bons enseignements qui donne des choses
constructives c'était minable c'est très
bien mais quand il tombe sur des
personnes qui agissent avec un sentiment
de vengeance qui leur transmettent ce
sentiment de revanche qui peut être
nauséabond pour la citoyenneté de ces
jeunes et bien sacré des dégâts aussi
dit justement vous pensez quel type de
chapitres de l'histoire qui pourrait
donner des idées de vengeance à ces
jeunes et qui serait éludée par
l'éducation nationale
on parle de laisse moi je vais vous
donner un exemple très simple
voilà souvent lorsque je fais des
réunions avec mon association on parle
que ce soit avec d'autres associations
avec des mères avec des écoles je leur
pose la question est ce que vous
connaissez le scandale 2970 dollar une
beaucoup de gens vous disent non par
exemple en 1970 cependant que dans la
sainte france catholique l'avortement
était interdite eh bien il faut savoir
que dans certains territoires des dom
tom
on faisait avorter de force des femmes
noires et qu'il y avait des panneaux
publicitaires
voyez des femmes noires avec plusieurs
enfants et comme slogan c'était écrit ça
suffit il a fallu que le média par match
face une enquête là bas et qu'ils
fassent remonter l'information en
métropole pour que ces choses puissent
être attribués
donc il y a beaucoup d'épisodes comme ça
la france est un merveilleux pays mais
si on veut aller de l'avant
on doit apprendre à la fois les épisodes
glorieux mais aussi les épisodes
douloureux c'est comme pour un mariage
lorsque l'on subit ou dans une union
lorsque l'on subit avec quelqu'un ne
vaut être au courant de tout pour ne pas
créer de déséquilibres par la suite tout
simplement
et ces jeunes ils ne sont pas bêtes
aujourd'hui internet c'est quelque chose
de puissant mais c'est quelque chose de
très dangereux aussi
alors qu'on les gestionnaires ayant de
très dangereux avec peut-être aussi
beaucoup de manipulations je ne sais pas
voilà quel est votre avis là-dessus mais
mais tout à fait mais vous avez de tout
sur internet
vous avez des personnes qui font bien
leur travail mais vous avez des
personnes aussi qu'ils manipulent et
lorsque les jeunes tombent sur des
manipulateurs et ben ça peut faire des
dégâts
mais déjà ce qu'il faut c'est que on
doit avoir cette impression on doit
avoir cette assurance que l'on soit en
français d'origine bretonne je fais
exprès de parler comme ça d'origine
corse d'origine savoyarde d'origine
algérienne d'origine congolaise
on doit être en paix avec l'histoire de
france non pas pour accuser pour dire
ceci cela mais pour pouvoir avancer de
l'avant sans avoir l'impression qu'il y
à des pans entiers de l'histoire qui
sont mis sur sous le couvercle on ne
sait toujours pas pourquoi
et la dernière chose qu'il est important
de rappeler c'est que quand on voit la
considération de l'homme et de la femme
noire
même si aujourd'hui moi je vais pas dire
que la france est un pays de caux leur
aujourd'hui je suis français je suis
fier d'être français
mais il ne faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que les stéréotypes qui ont été
créés pour justifier ce c'est ce système
qui monte de l' esclavage perdure
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui lorsque l'on voit au niveau
de certaines élites notamment la
considération de leurs normes voix pour
la recherche de logement pour la
recherche de travail
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pourquoi
parce que il y à tout un tas de préjugés
qui sont en fait des fausses vérités qui
condamne des personnes est en réalité on
a broyé des milliers et des milliers
destiné à cause de ces projets
fallacieux aujourd'hui quand vous voyez
ces jeunes parce qu'il me semble être
très jeunes ces manifestants qu'on a
aperçu qu'on voit en tout cas sur ces
images en direct vous les voyez vous
auriez un jeune comme ça en face de vous
qu'est ce que vous auriez envie de lui
dire ce soir face aux vêtements là je
leur dirai de rentrer chez eux
l'importance et ces jeunes en fait faut
les encourager à reprendre confiance en
l'action citoyenne les encourager à se
réengager dans la nation c'est très
important mais il faut comme je disais
qu'ils aient l'impression d'être
considérés comme de véritables français
de d'être acceptée pleinement dans leur
francité
parce que lorsque vous avez des
personnes je ne citerai pas les noms
qu'ils disent je vous confrères que les
gens qui habitent dans les quartiers
il orchestre leur ghettoïsation et qui
ils ont intérêt à se retrouver en eux en
tre pardon parce qu'il y aurait un plan
de grand remplacement ou autre tout ça
c'est des bêtises lorsque vous
travaillez dans les quartiers vous
verrez que les personnes se plaignent
justement pas ne se plaignent pas d'être
entre eux mais ils se plaignent d'être
mis sur le côté date ni sur le pas de la
société et on ne revient toujours à la
même question
entièrement français ou français
entièrement à part ou français à part
entière ou est ce que ces jeunes peuvent
se retrouver par rapport à tout cela et
c'est une source de confusion lorsque
vous avez des jeunes qui grandissent
avec quelque part cette dichotomie
j'ai même presque envie de dire 7
septembre cette menace de l'apatridie
psychologique de ne pas se sentir
accepté comme totalement français mais
ne pas avoir forcément de racine avec le
pays d'origine et ben là on se retrouve
dans une situation très dangereuse avec
des gens qui sont perdus et qui
aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus précoce
c'est sûr ça aussi qui vont faire
attention
ils sont de plus en plus précoces et ils
ont de moins en moins peur par rapport
au fait de mener des révoltes de mener
des actions et je répète quand je dis ça
je ne légitime pas la violence mais ils
n'auraient rien à perdre ce land où ils
sont en tout cas dans cet état d'esprit
certains oui certains oui ils ont un
sentiment d'abandon
quand il voit depuis plusieurs
générations quand ils voient leurs
parents
quand tu vas leurs grands parents qui
ont trimé pour pour leur donner des
valeurs mais qui vivent en deçà en
dessous du potentiel qui peuvent
apporter à la france tout simplement
parce qu'ils sont plaque parce qu'ils
sont arabes parce qu'ils sont asiatiques
ça leur fait mal au coeur et c'est comme
ça aussi que malheureusement se
développent des sociétés souterraine où
vous avez des jeunes qu'on vous leur
parlez vous ai pas dit mais écoute
reprend des études va travailler qui
vous répondent les écoutes moi je fais
tant d'argent par jour ou par semaine
pourquoi est-ce que je vais aller faire
un travail où je vais être surpayé
pourquoi je vais aller que dans l'airé
dans un système qui ne m'accepte pas il
faut prendre en compte en fait qu'est ce
qui se passe psychologiquement au sein
de la population et ce qui est difficile
c'est que lorsqu'il s'agit des jeunes
des quartiers prioritaires
on ne fait pas ce travail mais lorsqu'il
s'agit moi j'avais vu quand il
s'agissait des gilet jaune quand il
s'agit des agriculteurs quand il s'agit
du personnel pénitencier dont on parle
que vous avez énormément de suicide
quand il s'agit d'autres structures de
la société on prend le temps de savoir
ce qui se passe lorsque vous aviez pu le
avoir des manifestations de la cgt de la
cfdt ou d'autres syndicats et qu'il y
avait des voitures qui étaient brûlés
dans paris qu'il y avait des vitrines
qui a été cassé on ne voyait pas sur les
plateaux télé des pseudo-experts venir
traiter ces personnes de racailles
mettait qu'il s'agit les jeunes de
quartiers prioritaires
le mot racaille sort très rapidement et
c'est très facile que quand une personne
se fait arrêter
on va tout de suite rechercher quelle
est son casier judiciaire toujours pour
atténuer le potentiel bien fait que
cette personne peut apporter à la nation
donc effectivement il un style et un
sentiment de ras-le-bol et je ne pense
pas qu'on soit encore arrivé au point de
rupture c'est pour ça que il faut
prendre ce qu'il se passe là comme un
avertissement important et aussi il faut
qu'on puisse mettre en garde toutes les
personnes qui pensent un petit peu comme
moi quand toutes les toutes ces
personnes qui dès demain vont avec tout
bête sur la tête dassa traoré allez dire
que voilà
elle a réuni des racailles et puis c'est
de sa faute et tout ça non moi j'invite
vraiment l'ensemble des français cette
france qui galèrent cette france qui
souffre
cette france qui subit les injustices
peu importe la couleur de
oh je les invite pas la violence mais je
les invite à s'unir pour réfléchir pour
voir comment est-ce que l'on peut
construire cette france de demain et
comment est-ce qu'on peut quitter ce
stade d'avoir sur le même territoire qui
est un territoire merveilleux mais bien
mal aux merci merci beaucoup en tout cas
un bel bruit président de l'association
forces républicaines d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france de nous
avoir apporté votre point de vue sur
cette situation avec ces incidents à
paris on le disait en marge d'une
manifestation en soutien
en tout cas organisée par le comité de
soutien d'adama traoré on va y retrouver
notre reporter thomas bonnet qui se
trouve toujours en direct devant le
tribunal judiciaire de paris où a débuté
aux alentours de 19 heures cette
manifestation qui était calme au départ
d'ailleurs pendant de plusieurs heures
et qui a dégénéré par la suite thomas
quel est l'état d'esprit l'atmosphère
sur place
côté on n'est plus vraiment devant le
parvis du tribunal je vais vous montrer
sur ces images où nous sommes nous
sommes de l'autre côté du périphérique
où un petit groupe de manifestants est
toujours présent et au loin il ya encore
des forces de l'ordre il faut dire
qu'ils ont utilisé beaucoup de gaz
lacrymogène de l'autre côté du
périphérique ce qui a contraint les
manifestants à quitter le parvis et les
alentours en fait du tribunal de paris
la situation est très confuse puisqu'on
voit au loin des pompiers peut-être que
vous pourrez les apercevoir sur ces
images des pompiers qui interviennent à
priori sur sur un feu on imagine en tout
cas ils sont entourés des forces de
l'ordre des forces de l'ordre présentes
en nombre puisque de l'autre côté du
périphérique il ya aussi d'importants
dispositifs policiers est alors qu à
l'instant même vous voyez du gaz
lacrymogène vient d'être tiré à nouveau
et ce qui conduit à chaque fois à ces
mouvements de foule dont on a désormais
pris l'habitude ces deux là c'est
malheureux ce soir on a pris l'habitude
de mouvements de foule dès que gaz
lacrymogènes sont tirés et bien les gens
quittent quitter les lieux
c'est sont très confuses merci
thomas bonnet alors que effectivement
une partie du périphérique parisien a
été envahi tout à l'heure par les
manifestants on continue donc de
commenter ces images et de réagir dons
soit vous en direct par téléphone avec
eric coquerel député de la france
insoumise de la première circonscription
de seine-saint-denis bonsoir et
concrètes vous avez vous participé à la
manifestation tout à l'heure une
manifestation calme au départ qui semble
dégénérer alors qu'il est quel est votre
réaction
écoutez moi je pense qu'il faut surtout
retenir vu les événements
c'est une manifestation historique parce
que c'est plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de personnes happées par le comité à
damas contre les violences policières
les discriminations assise et j'ai envie
d'action que j'ai jamais vu autant de
noms de rassembler pour un événement de
ce titre une manifestation calme radical
est terminée bon j'ai pas envie de bon
qui se termine par pékin
quelques qui est tous des chauves souris
mais il me semble mineur par rapport à
l'importance de la manifestation
et c'est pas bon il frappe était soit il
n'empêche
effectivement vous dites c'est à dire
effectivement l'invité président au
majin messaoudène il faut se rappeler
des belles images des belles choses du
calme pourquoi selon vous ça se termine
toujours aussi mal ces manifestations
toute manifestation et est actuellement
technip et à tuer actuellement il ya des
techniques policières de leur pression
par rapport à des manifestations et vous
savez très bien que j'ai tout gardé des
délais comme un grain des fois pour y
former us à leurs wc sur gc sur la
bouffe ici il y avait pierre
manifestations violentes et des lacs
c'est le lynx
tous sont sortis très vite donc j'ai pas
envie ce soir 2-2 du futé des techniques
policières
le groupe de discuter d'événements qui
me semblent marginaux par rapport à
l'importance de la visitation encore une
fois c'est le nom de joint cité la
nationalité cela est tout
ils ont maintenant une réaction on s'est
créé actions et enfin le fait d'assumer
il y a un problème pas seulement de
bavures individuelle mais il ya un
problème systémique dans la police en
clair qu'il est qualifié loin de là ce
sont sont ornés de d'actes violents au
terme d'un simulacre oracle et ça veut
dire malheureusement que le gouvernement
fait le front et du fou dont on voit un
très bel des stades par rapport à tout
ce qui est des solistes capitaine voilà
maintenant il faut réagir ce qu'on veut
pas à réagir quand l'acculturation des
états unis parce qu'on tient approche
dans le bain grimaud aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement est ce que vous nous parler
du gouvernement mais ce que c'est un
gouvernement que vous jugez
exclusivement responsables de cette
situation
ou pour vous finalement ces problèmes ne
datent pas d'aujourd'hui
ils datent pas d'aujourd'hui une
gouvernement ont fait beaucoup c'est à
dire il a utilisé qui abhorre la police
pour faire face à des leviers d'action
sociale on y doutant pas apporte un
moment où acheter un truc dit même prêt
spécial dans la juste dans la police à
lutry les éléments les plus violents
jalibert donné le ton voilà souvent avec
la le silence voire la complicité de la
part du gouvernement moi ça fait
plusieurs fois que je pose des questions
orales au gouvernement
c'est quand même hallucinant qu'un seule
réponse c'est plus que jamais pas dire
qu'il ya un problème
toutes les études le montrent la gale et
il ya le défenseur des droits qui
viennent parler de de discrimination
systémique dans la police vous savez
comme moi que l'ex urss s'intéresse pas
aux récentes qui ont été sorties qui
n'ont que quand vous êtes racialisée non
racisées dans ce pays il avait six à
huit fois plus de risques d'être
contrôlées et tout rien sans rien avoir
commis que vous êtes donc on a un
problème alors je sais bien quelques
policiers ont vu c'est pas évident est
souvent le dernier fusible face à un
recul de l'état social
c'est vrai que la police n'a pas un rôle
facile mais la police a aussi des droits
qui sont celui d'exercer le monopole
violence légale et à partir de là à
gouvernement ne peut pas laisser penser
que elle peut agir certains moments en
pensant qu'elle fait presque justice
elle même comme avec le jeune gabriel
encore il ya quelques jours a bondi de
14 ans et qui risque aujourd'hui de
perdre son oeil dont il faut envoyer un
message fort et moi je suis chef c'est
la meilleure manière de montrer son
attache à des principes
d'une police républicaine que justement
d'une passe de ne pas laisser faire et
de prophéties comme ce soir nous l'avons
fait l'amateurisme alors à l'origine
évidemment de cette colère des
expertises judiciaires dont une vendredi
qui a écarté la responsabilité des
gendarmes un peu avant 20 heures une
nouvelle contre expertise médicale
indépendante
cette fois-ci réalisées à la demande des
proches du jeune homme qui ont bel qui a
validé l'asphyxient par le placage
ventrale contredit donc ainsi la
dernière expertise judiciaire qu'ils
discutent les gendarmes comment eric
coquerel vous vous expliquer sa ses
différentes expertises
est ce qu'il ya une forme de
manipulation se vend vous vous n'iriez
pas jusque là
moi ce que je crois déjà quelques il
faut maintenant avoir une france
indépendante
ils jugent des policiers ça peut plus
être l'igpn c'est le cas d'ibm en
exception française dans une situation
de ce type et je remarque aussi et que
quand il n'y a pas de vidéo enregistrée
je parle de ça parce que vous savez qui
est un projet de loi d'eric ciotti
dillon à ne plus diffuser de telles
vidéos on n'y a pas de vidéo diffusée
ils sont indéniables comme par exemple
avec le jeune samir ya pas longtemps à
l'île saint denis où des policiers ont
eu des déclarations racistes et ben
c'est extrêmement difficile que la
justice est extrême et si que la crise
était comme on dira a produit des
violences absolument anormal pouvant
entraîner la mort donc voilà je ce que
j'observe c'est inédit pour adama ils
disposent de gens pays c'est le cas de
brahim abbas qui était un jeune il n'ya
pas longtemps dans le balboa des ont pu
malheureusement faire église très longue
et très souvent ce sont des jeunes rate
is et trois mois ce sont deux des jeunes
d'origine très populaire on appelle du
social donc une double discrimination
qui s'établit voilà pourquoi je crois
qu'il faudrait entamer une réforme
profonde de la politique aujourd'hui une
réforme profonde de la police mais
peut-être aussi et surtout le changement
de certaines mentalités
c'est indispensable selon vous oui mais
les mentalités avant tout la police et
un corps de fonctionnaires
donc à partir de là l'état doit prendre
la responsabilité le gouvernement de
prendre ses responsabilités si le
gouvernement à chaque fois qu'il ya une
violence policière son premier réflexe
et découvrir
comme pendant les manifestations en tout
simplement partout en réalité c'est sa
dernière protection à un certain moment
pas de stabilisation sociale qui le
gouvernement fait ça il faut pas y avoir
de changement donc le premier problème
cf quel ordre politique sont donné
qu'elle est lequel et quelles sont les
consignes qui sont données
et moi j'aime bien je le dis il faut il
faut des moyens policiers les brillants
les policiers sont n'ont pas assez de
moyens nous pas assez d'hommes ont bien
faire leur travail mais aussi
l'information il qu'on revient à une
vraie police de proximité en finir par
exemple avec les la bac les toutes ces
compagnies qui arrivent de l'extérieur
dans des quartiers du coup j'allais dire
arrive y arrivons dans une situation
très vite l'attention tension
il faut en finir avec les les d'armes
s'est elle d'aider les autres il faut en
finir avec les gt n chercher une autre
instance indépendante juges et les
policiers dansent et à faire bref il
faut donner le ton et ça c'est politique
après moi je suis sûr que il ya une
grande majorité de policiers qui
seraient ravis de cette inclinaison
parties sont profondément républicain
mais simplement aujourd'hui c'est celle
ci qui cède système c'est parce qu'ils
pensent que en dernière instance il ya
une impunité par rapport aux éléments
violents y aura-t-il de la police merci
au rhic et les cas coquerel député la
france insoumise de la première
circonscription de seine-saint-denis
d'avoir réagi donc à ces incidents
incidents dont on le disait en marge de
cette manifestation cet après-midi et
jets de projectiles tirs de gaz
lacrymogène manifestants sur le
périphérique barricades des incidents
qui ont donc éclater ce soir en marge
d'un vaste rassemblement à paris pour
dénoncer notamment les violences
policières et après cette nouvelle
expertise expertise sur la mort d'adama
traoré tués lors d'une interprétation
c'était en juillet 2016 nouvelle
expertise indépendante à la demande des
proches du jeune homme qui ont donc
validé l'asphyxient par le claquage
ventrale et contredit la dernière
expertise judiciaire qui dit disculper
les gendarmes 1 pour continuer donc de
commenter ces événements nous sommes en
direct avec rocco contento secrétaire
départemental paris unité sgp police
bonsoir contento merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france j'imagine que
vous suivez ces événements on a entendu
plusieurs invités effectivement nous
parler de ce malaise entre souvent ces
jeunes issus des banlieues la police on
ne cesse effectivement de commenter avec
vous aussi les policiers sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui que vous inspirent ces
images mais écoutez si tu es une
manifestation pied levé par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé sur la dernière
expertise
excusez-moi de adama traoré et il faut
savoir que c'est un vrai marathon médico
légal puisque les premières expertises
en 2016 avait dédouané les gendarmes
pour rappel c'était des gendarmes qui
étaient impliqués pas des policiers une
autre contre expertise ordonnée par le
juge d'instruction qui a mandaté trois
médecins dédouaner encore la
responsabilité des gendarmes puisqu'elle
stipulait que monsieur traoré étaient
décédées n'ont suite aux plaquages
rentrer a levé suite à un oedème
cardiovasculaires et l'a visiblement une
nouvelle expertise ce jour met en cause
les gendarmes
donc voilà c'est pas cessé ces deux
éléments totalement contradictoire je
pense qu'il faut attendre toute la fin
de cette enquête que lumière soit faite
et pour l'instant je mesurerai arguera
bien de d'émettre un avis sur cette
histoire malheureuse et rocco contento
effectivement
va se garder et tous d'émettre un avis
sur sur ses expertises judiciaires mais
il n'empêche comment vous expliquez vous
avez peut-être un avis que deux
expertises judiciaires écartent la
responsabilité des gendarmes
donc des expertises menées par le
tribunal demandé le tribunal et qu'une
nouvelle expertise tout d'un coup
indépendante incriminent les gendarmes
est ce que vous vous comprenez en tout
cas que ça fuit suscité la colère chez
les proches de ce jeune homme qui ont
perdu un fils un proche un enfant oui
complètement laborde un homme est
toujours triste a déploré
et c'est par contre ce que je ne
cautionne pas du tout c'est que les
personnes manifestent
soit c'est moi qui vais beaucoup de
monde 15 organisations devant tribunal
de paris d'ailleurs qui sait plus ou
moins bien passé dès le départ ce que je
ne cautionne pas ensuite ce sont
évidemment les violences les exactions
les dégradation du domaine public et les
incendies qui ont été provoqués sarr
toute colère ne légitime pas la violence
qui ont il faut pas daigné aussi qu' il
y a le l'effet états unis de ce qui se
passe en ce moment aux états unis donc
pas mimétisme
voilà ce qui faut absolument résoudre
effectivement à nous y travaillons nous
à lutter gp police nous sommes des
policiers républicains
c'est absolument faire en sorte de
rapprocher la police et la population
c'est important et voilà la police aidée
républicaine dans son ensemble il y a je
ne lis pas d épiphénomène ça arrive
c'est que c'est que les glaces sont
sanctionnés alors des fois ça dure plus
ou moins longtemps parce que les
enquêtes qui sont faites mais il n'y a
pas d'impunité chez les policiers
entendent nc coquerel qui expliqué
qu'ils avaient débuté total pour la
police non c'est que la france a
soumises nous a traités de barbares par
la voix de son président ça je me
rappelle de ça donc ce monsieur ne va
pas nous donner des leçons de morale
démocratie c'est vrai que de là
plusieurs invités un conseiller
municipal de seine saint denis m'a dit
messaoudène
cette impunité pour les policiers aucun
policier en prison je vous pose la
question est ce que les policiers aussi
sont réellement sanctionnés quand est ce
qu'on appelle des bavures
alors je peux vous dire que moi qui
siège en commission disciplinaire où il
ya le volet judiciaire qu'elle volet
administratif
vous savez que tous les mercredis bon là
dedans a payé pendant confinement vous
avez des policiers qui passe aux
commissions discipline et vous avez des
policiers parfois qui sont révoqués donc
en fait qui sont virés de la police
donc ça arrive on pas dire qu'il ya pas
qu il ya une impunité puisque moi je
suis même témoin de collègues qui sont
lourdement sanctionnés après dans les
enquêtes judiciaires qui sont assez
lourdes c'est vrai que ça prend beaucoup
de temps
mais voilà donc je fais confiance à la
justice de mon pays c'est une justice
qui est indépendante et on verra qui est
le verdict qui sera rendu par rapport à
la mort de ce jeune homme
monsieur traoré monsieur contento si
vous le voulez bien vous restez avec
nous pour commenter cette actualité on
va retrouver sur le terrain notre
reporter tom abonnés pour prendre le
pouls de la situation
thomas est ce que les choses
s'améliorent un petit peu où il ya
toujours un extrême climat de tension
qu'est ce que vous voyez sur place
écoutez ce n'est pas ni la tension est
toujours et toujours là à l'instant de
nos très nombreux gaz lacrymogènes ont
été tirées derrière moi sur la route ce
qui a contraint énormément de personnes
à quitter les lieux encore maintenant
l'air est difficilement respirable il ya
beaucoup de gaz lacrymogènes qui ont été
tirés résultat les des personnes sont
parties dans une rue qui est à côté de
l'endroit où il était jusqu'à présent
parfois ils retentent heureux de
retourner derrière mais il faut dire
beaucoup de forces de l'ordre qui sont
là et qui utilise à de très nombreuses
reprises les gaz lacrymogènes ya des
pompiers également qui sont intervenus
il ya quelques instants très compliqué
de vous décrire avec précision ce qui se
passe puisque de temps en temps on voit
les forces de l'ordre des fois on ne
voit pas les manifestants et bien
quitter les lieux il ya vraiment un
esprit de confusion qui règne en ce
moment on est vraiment de l'autre côté
du périphérique désormais à quelques
mètres du tribunal de paris
thomas bonnin effectivement on voit vous
frotter les yeux on va pas vous vous
tenir trop longtemps à l'antenne usage
de gaz lacrymogènes usage également de l
bd cette arme qui a été effectivement
très décrié très critiqué y compris par
le conseil de l'europe pendant les
manifestations de gilet jaune est ce que
vous en avez vu sur place sur le terrain
utilisé par les forces de l'ordre soient
non j'en ai non je n'ai pas pu en
constater par moi-même ça fait partie de
l'arsenal de défense de l'or donc
peut-être ils l'ont utilisée en tout cas
moi je n'ai pas été témoin
de l'emploi de l bd ce soir beaucoup de
gaz lacrymogène je vous le répète parce
qu'en fait il ya des groupes qui sont un
peu répartis autour du tribunal et les
forces de l'ordre veulent absolument
disperser ces manifestants et donc il
utilise pour cela beaucoup beaucoup de
gaz lacrymogène l'air est saturé depuis
maintenant plusieurs minutes voire même
plusieurs heures tout autour de du
tribunal merci thomas bonnet en direct
donc sur place si on va retrouver rocco
contento un secrétaire départemental
paris unité sgp police au togo contento
ces manifestations à peine le pays des
conflits mais en face d'eux aujourd'hui
du déconfinement vous craignez voilà
d'autres montée de violence les
prochaines semaines dans notre pays oui
complètement complètement il faut savoir
que ça c'est pas liée au dés confinement
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un mal être
social qui est important dans ce pays et
que nous attendons tous dès la rentrée
prochaine et peut-être même avant pas
des grosses manifestations puisque la
crise tout le monde subit la crise et
surtout aussi la police a de petites à
titre personnel à titre professionnel
donc c'est vrai que à mon avis nous
aurons des grosses manifestations à la
rentrée de septembre
et peut-être aussi avant donc oui c'est
à craindre effectivement quel est le
moral des troupes parce que on imagine
que du côté de la police ça doit être
compliqué
séquence très longue de manifestations
de gilet jaune puis voilà ce confinement
avec respect évidemment des restrictions
qui n'était pas aisé on
imagine comment vous vous préparer
justement assez nouvelle journée de
tension que vous craignez écouter
d'abord les policiers vont partir en
vacances parce que nous sommes dans une
période qui arrive de congés annuels
donc les policiers pour pouvoir un peu
s'y reposer pour beaucoup un prêt
pendant le confinement nous avons été
très actifs puisque même si c'est pas
notre coeur de métier
nous avons voulu faire respecter le
confinement tout simplement en
contrôlant les attestations 100 km en
métier c'était de moralement pas de le
faire et en plus nous devions
parallèlement luc et contraire toujours
la petite moyenne et grande délinquance
qui est toujours actuel qui ne s'est pas
arrêtée avec le confinement les bandits
prennent pas de vacances et donc voilà
donc nous avons une rentrée de septembre
qui va être à mon avis très compliqué
avec des manifestations et est peut-être
ce que nous craignons une convergence
des luttes
donc ben écoutez nous serons là et puis
nous essaierons de faire de notre
travail le mieux possible sachant que le
moral ni policier n'est toujours pas au
beau fixe aujourd'hui ça malheureusement
depuis quelques années vous parler de
convergence des luttes clairement dans
la police on se prépare à cette
manifestation qui allie ces jeunes qu'on
peut voir réussi des banlieues on peut
voir sur ces images de moins en moins
peut-être puisque les choses commencent
peut-être à se calmer dans les rues de
paris également les gilet jaune cela va
s'ajouter évidemment une crise
économique très violente
je pense qu'on aura un coût vous plaira
de manifestants d'horizons diverses
après la liberté de manifester les
constitutionnel que les gens manifestent
pour leurs conditions de travail
c'est très louable nous mêmes des
policiers nous l'avons fait au mois de
mai dernier et je peux vous dire une
chose c'est que nous ce que nous
veillions c'est qu'elle n'y a pas de
trouble à l'ordre public c'est ça qui
est important que les gens manifestent
c'est très bien elle est passée les
soignants d'ailleurs où on y rester je
pense à la rentrée vu leurs conditions
de travail et c'est très louable et nous
le comprenons et beaucoup de policiers
aussi le comprennent simplement que vous
savez comme moi par expérience que en
marge de cette manifestation qui sont en
général pacifique vous avez toujours des
éléments qui viennent casser et en
découdre et ces éléments là n'ont aucun
idéal e si ce n'est de casser et de
dégrader
sinon c'était une manifestation qui a
rassemblé plusieurs milliers de
personnes et qui était en tout cas très
calme pendant plusieurs heures avant que
cela dégénère merci encore contento
d'avoir été le secrétaire départemental
d'unité sgp police paris merci à vous et
on va retrouver avant de refermer cette
émission on va les retrouver à nouveau
notre reporter thomas bonne et thomas il
semble sur ces images que les la
situation s'apaise quelque peu est ce
que vous me confirmer cette impression
en tout cas sur ces images en direct sur
rt france oui il y aura moins de
rassemblement il ya un indicateur qui
est assez important c'est que les forces
de l'ordre dont on retirer le casque ce
qui vous savez en manifestation est un
signe d'apaisement
en tout cas que la situation est en
train de s'apaiser beaucoup de gens ont
semble-t-il quitté les lieux c'est tout
à l'heure donc de l'autre côté du
périphérique
la ville de clichy où il y avait des
petits groupes de manifestants il semble
avoir quitté les lieux pour la majorité
d'entre eux il reste encore quelques
groupes de manifestants ici ou là mais
la tension est redescendue d'un cran et
alors pour revenir sur sept sur sept
soit réel contraste il ya des tables
mans 2 2 étapes deux phases d'abord donc
ce rassemblement très massif plusieurs
milliers de personnes voire même
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui ont manifesté de manière
pacifique qui sont rassemblés de manière
pacifique
et puis donc c'était un celle qu'on n'a
pas vraiment pu observer on ne sait pas
vraiment ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres
mais il ya eu un moment donné où cette
manifestation cette confrontation entre
les crs qui était présent proche de ce
cortège et le cortège des choses ont
dérapé on ne sait pas vraiment pourquoi
mais toujours est il que dès que la
premier dès que le premier tir de gaz
lacrymogène a eu lieu est bien les
choses se sont envenimées et depuis ce
moment là la situation a échappé à tout
contrôle avec de fortes tensions donc
autour du tribunal de paris sur le
périphérique également est un peu aux
alentours mais la situation est
effectivement en train de se calmer un
calme qui peut être sera de courte durée
parce que je voyais des projectiles sont
à ce moment lancés sur les forces de
l'ordre qui vont re équipe et leurs
casques
je vous disais qu'ils avaient retiré
leur casque voulait plus le voir sur ces
images
vous avez retiré leur casque ils ont
désormais remis leur casque ce qui
signifie que les tensions reprennent je
vous parlais d'un calme précaire puisque
effectivement on n'est jamais tout à
fait sûr que les choses se calment nous
mais nous avons essayé de trouver des
endroits un peu plus calme parfois pour
réaliser des duplex et à chaque fois
qu'il y avait les yeux plex est bien les
choses sont trop longs ce seront vite
vite dégénéré à nouveau des projectiles
qui sont lancés on verra si les forces
de l'ordre ont répliqué en tout cas ils
ont équipé de deux cas ce qu'à nouveau
il y à des boucliers
on imagine on voit quelqu'un en train
d'armer je vois un policier en train
d'armer un un tir de gaz lacrymogène on
peut imaginer qu'il va s'en servir on
verra si c'est en notre direction je
l'espère pas évidemment voyez la place
qui était bien encore quelques instants
occupés par des personnes pacifiques et
bien il ne l'est plus puisque les forces
de l'ordre ont désormais le reçu des
projectiles et vont peut-être répliqué
merci beaucoup
thomas bonnet en direct donc de ces
manifestations une dernière réaction on
va les retrouver ont plutôt écouté
puisque on a perdu notre invité en
direct on va écouter l analyse alexis
poulain cofondateur du monde moderne il
était avec nous un petit peu plus tôt
dans la soirée alors que le
rassemblement contre les violences
policières organisée par le comité de
soutien d'adama traoré était largement
plus calme que maintenant écouter ce qui
était son analyse alors qu'il ya un
problème il ya un problème qui fait que
au sommet de la hiérarchie personne ne
veut s'en occuper alors il ya une vie pn
qui fait des enquêtes mais regardez
comme c'est compliqué d'avoir ne
serait-ce qu'un avis d'expert sur les
raisons de la mort d' adama traoré
plusieurs expertises et contre
expertises tout ça pour essayer de
discuter une technique criminelle le
placage ventrale qui devrait en fait ne
plus avoir lieu et qui est dénoncé par
les associations de droits de l'homme et
pas seulement par la famille d'adama
traoré donc c'est un vrai problème et je
crois que l'absence totale celui qu'on
entend pas sur ce sujet mais c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui évite de parler de ce sujet
là alors que aujourd'hui avec des lois
d'exception on interdit toujours le
rassemblement de plus de 10 personnes
on voit bien qu'on ne peut pas dans ce
contexte là interdire une manifestation
donc on a un vrai problème qui est celui
en fait des dénonciations et des actions
suite aux actes
raciste qui ont pu avoir lieu au sein de
la police nationale
alors il ya les enquête de l'igpn là
encore une fois elles sont elles sont
extrêmement décrié mais surtout il n'y a
pas de paroles assez forte de la part de
ce préfet l'allemand qui par exemple à
une époque lors des manifestations
dédiées les jaunes par les deux camps et
disait un citoyen qui n'étaient pas dans
le même camp que cette femme c'est
inacceptable de la part d'un préfet de
parler de corde et on était en irait
tout à l'heure avec un bel boli
président de l'association forces
républicaines pour lui le confinement
est une phase qui a exacerbé les
injustices personne ne va se réjouir
lorsqu'il ya des images de violence
lorsqu'il ya des images de feu des
images de casse mais il est important de
pouvoir se concentrer rapidement sur la
source du problème à savoir que vous
avez toute une partie de la population
toute une partie de notre jeunesse qui
vivent avec ce sentiment d'injustice au
quotidien et malheureusement il se
trouve que pour cette phase de
confinement a été une face qu'à
exacerber les injustices que ce soit
vous avez de la police mais vis-à-vis de
l'état on est sur un territoire où vous
avez malheureusement plusieurs france
qui se regardent avec méfiance
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que quand vous
êtes noir quand vous êtes arabe
quand vous êtes asiatique à avoir ce
sentiment permanent de devoir prouver sa
francité que lorsque vous dites que vous
êtes français
on va toujours vous demandez oui
français mais doux comme s'il y avait
des vrais français qui sont blancs et
défauts français qui ne sont pas de
phénotype blanc c'est un problème qui
dure depuis longtemps et qui n'a pas été
abordée et aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est une alerte pour l'ensemble de la
classe politique
je pense qu'il est encore temps de
régler la situation mais si nous
laissons encore les choses passé en 10
ans en résumant la situation disant que
c'est une bande de racailles qui est
venu casser non il faut aller à la
racine du problème et voilà en direct
sur rtl france nous suivons toujours ces
manifestations et tensions dans les rues
de paris pour réagir janvier colombie
porte-parole de l'association policière
huppé annie bonsoir monsieur merci
d'être avec nous pour réagir donc à
cette soirée de tension une
manifestation non autorisée mais qui
étaient calmes réunissant des milliers
de personnes et cette tension donc ces
dernières heures
quelle est votre réaction ce soir
bonsoir
voir tout d'abord un rassemblement de
20000 personnes non autorisées mais dont
la présence but pouvait être cela était
prévisible pouvait dans ce contexte là
être envisagé comme un problème
problématique
ce qu'on voit malheureusement n'est pas
n'est pas si étonnant que ça
malheureusement il ya il ya des mois que
la tension est forte entre le quartier
et les forces les forces de l'anp pour
des raisons complexes et variées qui
nécessiterait un temps plus long pour
l'évoquer pour l'analyser maintenant ce
que ça évoque sexy que on est dans une
contexte d'une situation qui je l'espère
restera contrôlable d'un point de vue
comme de l'autre on a vécu des
manifestations qui ont dégénéré dans une
très violente dans les mois qui ont qui
sont passés qui se sont écoulées il
faudrait éviter que à la crise sociale
très forte ne s'agrègent un climat cette
fois populaires issues des sites est
encore plus fort et qui s'agrège à tous
à ce mouvement social qui risque de
faire un
je dirais une synthèse sacré team de
tensions multiples et variées la
situation est très inquiétante
on est peut-être j'espère que ce n'est
qu'un qu'un feu de fait pas eu d'enfance
sur quoi on assiste est quand même très
violent et est pour toi d'inquiétude
c'est évident il ya une conjonction
effectivement d'événements on va
évidemment parler
voilà deux du mimétisme un petit peu ces
images qui nous viennent des états unis
l'effet d'un confinement division pour
les français notamment dans les
quartiers compliqué et cette expertise
dont on parle depuis tout à l'heure qui
incriminent les gendarmes contrairement
aux deux précédentes expertise pour vous
c'est voilà la goutte qui a fait
déborder l'eau du vase ce soir un petit
peu compliqué de répondre il faudrait
connaître le dossier
en détail si le magistrat a estimé qu'il
n'y avait aucune raison d'être un examen
des gendarmes mis en cause par la
famille c'est qu'ils avaient des motifs
à le faire après il faut ne faut pas
préjuger des suites qui seront données
au dossier vous savez témoin si ce n'est
le statut de témoin assisté peut
déboucher un moment donné sur une mise
en examen
donc il peut et on peut très bien
imaginer que dans les mois à venir ça
puisse malgré tout débouché sur sur des
on-dit rang sur une audience pénale donc
avoir une réponse pour les familles qui
semble-t-il est le but recherché
au travers de cette manifestation dans
fin de ce rassemblement qui a dégénéré
en manifestations violentes
donc je pense qu'il faut être très
vigilant très vigilant au climat qui
règne et cette vigilance doit être le
fait pas simplement des dépôts petit des
magistrats mais également des politiques
si on fait si on ne prend pas la peine
d'analyser ce qui se passe dans ce pays
on va dans le mur c'est évident et il
faudra pas encore une fois que tout ça
se réduisent à une confrontation police
citoyenneté on l'a répété temps tant et
tant de fois au travers de l'association
et pmi depuis que la situation était et
socialement et au niveau de la
délinquance complexe qu'il faudrait
quand même un moment donné que devon
question soit posée et qu'on y apporte
aussi t'il possible les bonnes réponses
aujourd'hui quand on entend voilà
certains observateurs un certain parti
politique nous dire il ya une impunité
envers les policiers quand ils
commettent des bavures on les punit pas
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
obligé de défendre les policiers de dire
non les hommes et les femmes policiers
dans ce pays ne sont pas racistes ça
vous inspire quoi vous vous dites que la
situation est arrivée à un point guard
vous avez vous vous devez employer pour
vous utilisez des pertes qui en fait
président totalement la situation
c'est à dire qu'on est dans un contexte
où on selon les échos mondiale et le
dialogue lit la davie se résume à des
slogans contre sedan il faut aller plus
loin que ça qui est dommage c'est qu'il
n'ya pas tous les policiers ne sont pas
parfaits et en face il ya malgré tout
même une position qui soit les tissus de
la délinquance ou de l'opposition
sociale son prix fort qu alors
s'arquebouter sur des concepts vie
la police n'a jamais tort est aussi
intelligent que de dire que les
délinquants sont tous blancs bleus enfin
ces attentes sont vraiment espérer il
faut souhaiter que les gens qui ont des
choses intéressantes à dire et qui ont
des désirs et des analyses porteuse de
solutions prennent la parole soit
entendue plus forts que ceux qui ne
raisonnent que parent je répète que par
ce slogan tout n'est pas blanc tout
n'est pas noir que ce soit d'un côté
comme de l'autre il va falloir se donner
la peine d'y réfléchir
en tout cas la sueur à quoi on assiste
démontre malheureusement que toute
politique pénale toute politique
judiciaire en tout politique
je dirais d'implantation de police dans
les quartiers est de plus en plus
compliqué parce que ce n'est pas que
dans ce secteur de paris ou dans des
secteurs très ciblée de la région
parisienne qu'il ya des problèmes il y a
des problèmes de ce genre ou du moins
des tensions de ce genre par tous au
territoire national il va fort un moment
donné qu'on fera qu'on arrête de faire
semblant qu'il n'existe pas fait
problème
merci beaucoup aux jean-pierre colombiès
porte parole de l'association aux
policiers rupéni d'avoir été avec nous
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information et
surtout le live continue le lait de ces
événements de ces incidents qui sont en
cours actuellement dans paris qui semble
marquer un petit peu le pas mais rien
n'est moins sûr nous disait thomas
bonnet dans notre reporter à suivre donc
sur notre site internet
rt france point tv excellente fin de
soirée à tous sur arte france prochain
journal demain matin 7 heures du matin
heure française quand à moi j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver demain à 20
heures
excellent antoine à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois par skype depuis
bamako au mali aminata traoré